all it is happy Wednesday off the rails
and what better off the rails to be with
than Jimmy Lee the Jersey Outlaw
although today he's not here who's here
today
Dr wienership Dr wieners in the house
you got that Chanel glasses too yep for
Chanel glasses for you for this in New
York two weeks ago wonderful not cheap
either no it does look nice how much
were they eight
eight large 800 yeah that's pretty
pricey that's very and I never spent on
sunglasses so what was it for coming on
the show today well it's because in
social media in New York I'm I'm getting
more vibier uh glasses rather than the
plain ones so we're going with white so
I splurged on one pair
for The Vibes yeah yeah for the fomo uh
today's episode is sponsored by
expressvpn thank you to our sponsor we
love love
yeah Jimmy came all the way in from uh
New Jersey yep and uh what a momentous
occasion to be on the show with us today
because you just hit one million one
million followers on Instagram and the
crew is is loving it and we're all
loving it and well hard work does pay
off it sure does and I mean it's just
it's so incredible that um you're making
such amazing strides on Instagram yes
and how gram is our driver what
Instagram's our driver on our social
media that's the big Drive platform for
us yeah and what do you what do you
associate how do you how do you explain
the tremendous growth we're seeing on
Instagram and you're in your follower
account you know and I know without you
there would be no me
what's that sorry I was just telling Dan
that my TV doesn't work go ahead oh
without without H3
I don't think I'd be where I'm at you
guys have such a large fan base and
you've been kind to me and uh I'm
starting to pick up steam because I come
out to uh California a lot now well let
me ask you this yes because you're on
track to pass me on Instagram oh yes you
are
how many followers do you have I like
2.2 million I'm not even close to you I
know but at the pace you're growing
let's pull up the stats I mean you're oh
I can't yet because uh we're having an
issue with the display monitor oh I have
two million I I think I've I think I've
lost some to be honest during the uh
the Calamity of my career what what's
that mean I just I I've I've lost a lot
of fans in the past couple years levers
because of my uh political
associations okay people don't like when
I hang out with mega people like you so
they unsub me
the opposite the opposite oh yeah I'm
losing I'm losing Mega people you
shouldn't be losing people let's see so
Jimmy Lee here's your stats
you know more than me wait why does it
say 237
you gained 40 000 followers yesterday
Jimmy that's insane wow it's like she I
don't even track none of this so how did
you gain 40 000 like I mean that's
that's like I think we were advertising
that we're coming here you were yeah and
so the people are following yeah Street
work
it's just incredible because well how do
you even compare growth that much it's
like one of the top accounts probably
like what is Selena Gomez gain on a
daily basis
just curious or or one of the
Kardashians they they gain way more than
me are you sure no I don't track this
well let's take I'm just hustling and
I'm I'm keep going and going and going
no I know it's incredible and I'm trying
to just acknowledge you're incredible
I'm waiting waiting for my Tick Tock
account to catch up to my Instagram
account videos do well there yeah some
but they were doing better a while back
on Tick Tock YouTube I'm not YouTube
um Instagram seems to be doing the best
we have good YouTube videos up too have
you considered buying followers on Tick
Tock or is that more challenging Olivia
won't let me she won't let you no
why is that Olivia
um
she told me not to do it and I yeah I
told you I do whatever she asked me to
do in fact she asked me if I jump off a
building I said not again you know what
I changed my mind about that part I
don't want you to do that anymore oh you
know did she tell you to buy followers
on Instagram no no you would never do
and you're not doing that no never never
stop with the tomatoes you're killing it
because what would the point be of
buying followers they're not real it's
not organic right yeah because if you
buy
followers they're it's not really it's
fake right and why who would do that
I don't think you order man I I haven't
right
uh let's see have we got any evidence
about this tremendous growth uh
comparison
I just think for the hype coming out
here to be honest and also I do want to
mention we have a film and documentary
film coming out on me uh next month
there's a great filmmaker in New York
who does documentaries named Alex Novell
who reached out to me about a month ago
and we've been shooting for about a
month about six times and we put a
trailer together a week ago and uh he's
working on the film and should come out
in October okay it's a story of me
trying to be famous
uh stats are I have to say something
weird if you go to
um this is Jimmy's right yeah if you go
to Thursday
and you go to Selena on Thursday
do you add more followers than Selena
Gomez number one instagram account
are you kidding me it's right here the
stats right here Olivia is that true
foreign
you had 49 000 new followers wow
yesterday you had 41 000 new followers I
think that's Wednesday go ahead oh
she's not up here on Wednesday
but she's doing about uh 40 000 per day
so you are doing Lots we're matching her
almost a little head you think what
happened on Sunday and Monday it's like
the faucet turned off for a second good
question makes no sense I don't know why
oh she's number three in the world
geez
and how much does it cost to buy a
thousand followers
you tell me oh okay I don't know I don't
know okay
and then you and so it's really is
organic it looks super organic very
organic here we have um
where are most your fans located do we
have a geographical uh I have no clue
I would assume it I don't Mason
does all this stuff oh Mason does this
well he does all the I put the post up
but he does all the images for me do we
have the geographical location report
I believe that's only in his analytics
yeah we gotta see his phone yeah oh can
we can I see your phone yeah I just want
to see where your your fan base is
located oh you can do it too if you know
how if you're more comfortable with him
I'd like to do it we'll do it later he's
doing uh no no no no we'll do it all
right this isn't I mean this is huge
you're gonna pass Selena Gomez
hold on
but anyway it's a pleasure to see you
it's always a joy yeah you know how to
work yeah yeah that's my thing one
million that's got to feel good huh
feeling good feeling good one M baby 1M
one all right so let's see if I go to
um thank you hey Liv can I get a ice
water
sorry about that we should uh
you want anything else you want a coffee
or something yeah I just want to drink
something just like the ice like that
the water yeah so let's take a look here
so you can see on the phone
so we're at insights
I don't know if you're like me you don't
know how to do it either do you oh stop
it Jimmy you know how to do this stuff
my kids do all this stuff I'm trying to
see the geographical I thought it would
be an insights oh you're getting a call
from somebody on Instagram
call-in you got calls through Instagram
video what does that even mean I think
that's you guys because you did that
last time I was on an answer
hello
hey
who is this
is a Canadian uh Diplomat for the Jersey
Outlaw here okay
who is that I wish y'all could see his
phone he just called you oh okay it's
actually somebody real yeah
could I I wish y'all could see it
Jimmy's uh phone desktop it just
messages of saying hi Ethan and
like that yeah they don't care about me
no one cares about me oh no you have all
your notifications on this madness man
so Colin are you how did you call us can
I ask
on the Canadian diplomat IC Jersey
Outlaw do you know him he doesn't know
you no what's your name
what's your name
Colin hi Colin
all right thanks Colin thanks Colin we
appreciate it promise he becomes
unnecessary we'll we'll give you hey
Colin oh Jimmy has a question perhaps
all right bye-bye all right bye-bye
Colin appreciate the call oh that's cool
that you have that option available to
now we're getting calls from all kinds
of people Jimmy I mean here let's why is
this are we taking callings well I don't
know your phone's just blowing up hey um
hey
man hey Sam I'm sorry how do I say your
name Sanam um oh that's my that's
something that's that's my social media
girl oh hi Honey hi nice to meet you
I'll see you uh Friday night Friday
night
did you call to say hi did you know
yeah I'm watching live oh you're you're
the best and um what do you do for Jimmy
now that I've got you on the phone
the girls
she's just a girl she's honestly a fomo
girl not a social media girl oh she's a
father like Grace she was in New York
just comes out to hang but she's not a
social media you pay her to be fine no
she just comes out she's a fan she comes
out
oh Jimmy you can't ask me she's cheap
yeah real cheap that's why she doesn't
work for you anymore she's cheap Phenom
thank you for being a good fomo girl for
our boy okay see you Friday honey see
you Friday honey all right take care
nice to see you nice to see you we have
another call coming from Henry Gibb
let's see what they're up to now you're
gonna get all calling well I don't know
I'm holding your phone it's out of
control it's funny Henry
your phone is blowing up brother no
they're calling because of you do people
ever call your phone like this no just
cause I'm on
okay hold on Allison
Allison
you missed a call from Allison you want
to call her
Jesus Christ bro your is crazy
right now
you don't even know you're as bad as me
on the phone why do you have so many um
notifications on oh I think your phone's
blowing up because I I accepted too many
calls
end and accept decline let me decline oh
dude there's like a thousand calls yeah
we're gonna have to um Dan come here Dan
we're gonna have to deal with the set
well hold on it's too many people
calling because you took two calls
sorry guys I his phone is short
circuiting here
I can't even use it it's just non-stop
calls Jimmy why is this enabled you got
to work on the notification settings
here
just hit X's how are you going to do
anything and people keep calling
when they realize you see how many X's
I'm hitting yeah when they realize
you're not gonna answer they'll stop I'm
not answering guys stop calling please
there's no best to do with show there's
no better way to do this please guys
stop calling there's something
wait hold on I got to see the G I can't
even check the stats because people keep
calling remind me again remind me
guys here I'll turn it off for one hour
for one hour
can we turn off God
stop with the tomatoes Jimmy how do you
live your life like this man it doesn't
happen it only happens because I'm on
people don't people just keep calling
Dan all right here I'm gonna hand this
to love because he's our social media
Guru and he's gonna you crunch number so
I don't have to do this
love when you're uh maybe when you're
done can Danny have the phone back to do
stuff okay all right we'll get around to
Danny all right Danny what are you
filming for Jimmy just just shots for
Instagram and stuff yeah social media
because we were doing all that we'll
we'll get you you can use our stuff okay
no offense to Danny I'm sure he's got
good stuff there too we have a phone you
can use too if you want extra stuff you
know I don't want to take away from the
experience from you okay thank you buddy
ah
careful Jimmy Lee
the Jersey outlaw
so how's life been it's good I'm uh on a
mission and as I go I explore different
things to do to try to help the latest
thing is to film and I'm hoping people
look at me more seriously as you know
being a comedian a musician and a
dentist and see these struggles you want
wait you said musician comedian and
dentist yeah and in which order are you
hoping well in the trailer it says
comedian
Dennis lasts only because this is an
entertainment thing we don't care about
Dentistry well they do I think what
makes the story interesting is a person
who's a professional dentist is seeking
fame older and is going through numerous
struggles and obstacles to make it and
that's what Alex is uh making the story
about he's making about an underdog can
make it or try to make it and that's
what is appealing to a viewer is you
know a person doing what I'm doing
people are like why is he doing that at
his age when he successful has money and
he has a family and all that and and
it's more like why why don't you pay
some more then if you have money why
don't you why don't you pay Samar
the social media people they come out
um and they work pretty much Gratis it's
been like that since I started
and uh I take everybody out to eat
because they want to hang out they just
want to hang out with the outlaw just
like a lot of people want to hang out
with you yeah right but I wouldn't I
wouldn't have someone work for me if I
didn't pay them so they're young kids
and they're they're just they're full of
a lot of hall now they're full of love
and and they just hanging Vibe don't
know any better and then and then when
they what was that don't know any better
yeah no just the way it is
I don't think it's that business no
because completely exploited no because
he's a he's a socialist no because
because I'll tell you why guys
I do not find any of these people they
DM me and every one of them finds me and
I an honest and I tell them I need
social media people I don't pay but I
take it I think we have a nice time and
do they have some people don't want to
do it and most of them do they just want
to go yeah they just want to be with you
yeah but they I created like an
experience and when we go in restaurants
the service and the treatment and the
love and it just creates an entertaining
experience let me ask you this when you
take them out for lunch lunch and dinner
lunch and dinner yeah oh that's nice
yeah and then do they order expensive
stuff or they get like a hamburger
what's nice about my teammate is
um no they really don't they do they
they don't come back right right we had
one doing that and she she doesn't come
back what did she what was she ordering
no she was over ordering and she was uh
a self-serving social media person for
her own career and uh really yeah and uh
so you sniffed out the bad one uh well
really really Mason snifter really Mason
sniffed around Mason's doing Mason did
it well what was she ordering was she
really ordering big at lunch was that
your first sign it was that and the way
the posts were going up and and things
that were happening behind the scenes
and I'm fomoing it up and I really don't
see it and um
Mason said it and uh there was another
person I forget that was on on my team
that said oh people are actually said it
people are
and who's on my team do we pay people no
oh
I'm honest no yeah no I won't lie again
are you paid
Dan is not paid no the man is here doing
your social media yes parking them
orders get get gas dad do you mind being
on camera damn gas money
yeah so Dan came with uh Dan is here
he's see he didn't Jimmy introduced you
as his social media guy but you don't
know who Dan is
do you remember the movie Get Shorty
with Chili
Palmer son Danny Palma that's true
go ahead go ahead yeah what do you want
to know so did you reach out to Jimmy uh
yeah he did one of those social media
posts and I just he reached out and are
you a fan of the show oh yeah dude I'll
be the fan since um
nice to meet you bro I mean we met
before briefly at the live show but nice
to see you again
and so how much work do you do for him
on a day like this honestly dude this is
just like a fun time like I just help
him post stories and like come up with
memes and captions and if he
offered you money would you take it I
mean of course obviously yeah yeah and
he goes well he helps me with gas money
he is wealthy yeah
he could afford it but
right like you wouldn't even notice
probably to give him like 50 bucks he
does he does oh you do yeah I am I am
and where did you guys get lunch today
yet or is that coming up later no no
we're we're gonna have dinner later
don't say that we're going somewhere
later okay and is it just you two or is
there other phone uh one other guy all
he might come by no no you know he's not
coming Pat's coming Paul he's not coming
Paulie's Uninvited
up last night and embarrassed us at the
restaurant wait what did Paulie do Dan
tell him you got to meet Paulie Paulie's
an interesting character he's like he's
like Jimmy but like jacked up to like 10
and doesn't know when to stop the bit
and so Paulie is a he's a fomo kid who
was hired for or uh recruited for
socials he's no no no
from here he was a little bit off his
rocker so what did Paulie do at dinner
Dan Talent that's what he always does he
drinks and he kind of gets wild he likes
to flex his uh watch what kind of watch
to the waiter and he's being rude to a
waiter and he's you've never done that
I'm super nice keep apologizing to the
waiter what kind of watch does he have a
Bulgari watch and nice I don't know yeah
but I have a nice watch too I'm not
going to sit and show everybody my watch
is that a nice watch Zach how much does
that watch cost piece of
well he told us last night it was 17.
then what is it anyone that brags about
the the cost of their watch right I I
have nice watches I don't even wear one
and say anything Zach give me one of
these did you know Zach has a nice watch
uh he showed it to me before you got
here yeah anyone that shows off their
watch is a tool man
actually speaking of Zach flexing his
talent there was
um today's Wednesday and we usually do
um an off the rails Video Edit okay I
got Artistry collaboration between Zach
and Ian
and today in honor of you Jimmy they've
put together somewhat of their Magnus
Opus really well I mean
I mean I I'm kind of grab my phone no
this year may want to well love has it
oh love did you say oh love I need my
phone it's in the Discord okay okay very
funny okay hold on can I have you know
as a social media as a social media
manager I would say that's completely
organic
just take a look all right well uh
before we go go to use that I got the
stats from your social media so first of
all this this I mean this is interesting
62 men
with 62 percent more than women which is
4. women well I have more men than women
yeah
but let's keep going through here
yes the age range is pretty looks pretty
good
here's the top geographical location
oh my goodness 76 is from Brazil you
know why why is that we're down there a
lot filming in Brazil you've been to
Brazil we've been there all last month
yeah right before the documentary Brazil
all July you I thought you're Brazil
absolutely wow filming for four weeks
you're with me Jimmy you have
never been to Brazil you're too soft for
that country Jimmy we were there and I
got to tell you he said they love us
well no kidding because that's like 700
that's 60 000 million that's why you see
the locations we filmed I gotta tell you
India is the second one you never went
but we do have a lot of Indian people
can I ask so if let's say theoretically
but that's how I like that now because
we were just there
no 760 000. we were there the whole
month of July filming
five days a week but how many followers
did you have a month ago because it was
probably eight hundred thousand so that
I don't know again I don't trap but I
just know Brazil's High because we were
there right but a month ago you were at
eight hundred thousand followers
probably seven yeah okay seven before
you went to Brazil so how do you know we
went to Brazil in July two months ago
okay let's say you were at 600 000. so
since then
that that means that you still have
hundreds of thousands three months ago
it was no I'm sure three months ago that
wasn't like that right because we
weren't in Brazil but that doesn't make
sense because you have 760 000 Brazilian
followers well they La they I gotta tell
you no but two months ago you had more
you sold if you saw the reaction of the
people in Brazil you would be mystified
he's big in the favelas you know it was
just they love us and the the chicks the
young Spanish ones they love this type
of Comedy because they don't have it
down there right
right
Dan what do you make of this 76 in
Brazil as a social media fomo expert I
mean he just has a big Latino and um
community that really supports him I
mean we look back at his life you know
Community if you look back at his
Instagram is one of our biggest fans so
give him my ignorance but his Brazilian
considered Latino South Americans close
enough afro Africa Jimmy is fluent in
Portuguese a lot of people don't know
that is that right no but I took Zach to
a bull fight once in Madrid did I tell
you no I got sick he did so we left you
got zigzag you got sick he didn't he got
nauseous from watching them put the
arrows in the Bulls oh that's nice from
all your Jimmy what's that it's
from all your who's
talking about
so yeah
um
now what's interesting let's say we know
you have a million followers and
congratulations by the way thank you for
that
one mil baby and so if you take 4.5
which is your not your United States
audience yeah but that changes now
this week the US will probably go up in
a week you have to watch it changes
based on where we shoot it does yes
that's how followers work well
that's how it's working for me see we've
never been to Indonesia 1.2 percent yeah
we never went point five percent yeah
that's strange
um so but I was saying let's just look
at it right now a snippet in time 4.5
would be 45
000 American followers that seems like
that would be a more accurate
representation of what I would expect
your Instagram followership to be well
that's too low it's too low yeah yeah 45
000. way low we get that in a day now
yeah yeah literally yeah I mean listen
I'm not gonna I don't want to brag but
I'm bigger than big yeah no that's true
huge huge big you're gonna pass me in
like a year no I'm not you are look at
this look at the
no Jimmy I'm not going to pass you how
could I pass you
the numbers don't lie brother I know I
know it's the it's that part is that
Brazilian follow they love you there the
Latin chicks love them there's no doubt
about that no doubt huge huge in Brazil
all right so Zach back to you I'm sorry
I had to report on that
um so Zach how did you what do you want
to say about this
say about what you're at Magnus opus
well I mean I've I'm big now you know
yeah you played stock is huge I uh I
played the Hollywood Bowl Hollywood Bowl
you're a big deal you're you big and uh
you know I'm just kind of beneath me to
do these uh little minuscule
intro beneath you people love it Zach
don't say that
this is who what made you who you are
today I mean don't exactly you are an
excellent musician I've I've evolved and
uh um I would make funny but the notes
on the guitar don't go that low
hilarious Jimmy
um what you said you would make funny
I'd make fun of him but the notes on the
guitar don't go that low which means
like a short joke I don't get it oh yeah
like
I don't know I didn't get it I didn't
get it no you didn't even get it that's
the beauty of the Jimmy Lee sometimes he
doesn't even get it bingo anyways all
right so you don't have one or you do
Zach I'm confused I don't know
all right so Zach sent me this video to
show
um I don't I don't know what this is
about he's saying he's gone big time and
this is his
you know experimental Masterpiece or
something so you sure you want to
Premiere that here Zach it might be a
ticketed event by the sound of it you
might be able to get to charge people to
do this live I just don't care anymore
dude yeah you don't care about Jack why
are you depressed Dale life is
meaningless
I think what happened is he's attained
all of his dreams and goals yes he's
he's sold out he's the triple threat
he's the First Act in what 20 years to
sell out he's huge the three venues and
uh I think he's just numb to it all yeah
I'm jaded as dude all right so
Playa let's see what it what the what is
this all about you like Rock and Roll
Jesus Zach
shalom shalom
all right so let's see I'm Zach Lewis
I'm Lego Lou I'm Golf Course Craig
zilizanka these voices inside of me are
cacophony now that I've played the
Hollywood Bowl I've evolved it's time
for my avant-garde era I'm going out to
record the sound of the world get in
touch with the spirit of Gaia
get in there
oh yeah you're a good leaf
get a little good little leaf give me a
shot of the watch
that's good that's good stuff I've
created musical fusion with the spirit
of my four Bears yeah
do you hear that
soak tree
and things
I'm one with the sound of mother nature
of God you know I'm gonna get some
really good sounds I'm gonna climb this
tree
[Music]
I'm feeling it a whisper in the grass a
tickle in the trees the musical notes of
Eternal salvation
the language of loss the language of
primordial memory
Oh yeah talk to me I want to hear you
the atmosphere Whispers sweet nothings
into my ear it gives my chakras the
tingles
where have you been
tell me your story
I know this language
this is Earth
this is the sounds of Earth
my ears are a tableau where Destiny has
etched its song across time and space
these aren't uh Panda dunks by the way
these are Jordan one high 85s
if you wear Panda dunks here
we gotta talk my sound bites are the
universe looking back at itself in
little fiery comets across the cosmos of
mine's eye
There's No Beginning No End
just Zack is this does this look cool to
you yes
you smell that
Zach's coming for you la sucking that
fat loogie don't spit it out because I'm
gonna record it
foreign
okay all right Zach good job well that's
interesting um
we're good we're doing uh how do you
call it when they do that for Hollywood
they get random oil fully follow Folly
you're doing Folly now yeah I might I
might say your careers
a little bit of folly down this path
you've been sitting next to Jimmy a
little too long in my workshop but now
we have the song that he made from all
this so he does have a song so Ian was
gonna like make all these like you know
stupid little visuals for it but I'm
like you really gotta let the audio
speak for itself so you guys are gonna
sit here for a minute and 18 seconds and
embrace its beauty
or what or what what are you gonna do
that sounded like a threat yeah you
don't want to know man all right I do
want to hear it okay you curious Jimmy I
want to hear it yeah all right so you
guys ready I'm a fan of Bob on Guard art
ready that's why I like Jimmy Lee thank
you sir I'm like uh you know this is my
Picasso you know here we go
help me
[Applause]
what the hell is this
Subway are we in a Subway Ethan I don't
I'm just in another round
it's just wonderful did I hear whale
sounds in that
a low battery fire alarm sound
I like it here we go
I liked it
what do you think love
's out
love is done this much longer
wow whoa
that was really good now that is that is
I know what it's giving uh it's gonna be
giving war zone it's giving Yoko Ono you
know what is giving me an Olivia
heartburn
is that right Olivia I didn't hear what
he said he says it's giving you a
heartburn yeah that's what it did me too
thanks so much you too yeah did we get
claimed for war zone the last time we
yeah we did it yeah that's crazy
it's a piece of piece of art you gotta
you gotta uh put that in the copyright
database Zach yeah
um so yeah that was my uh my masterpiece
you know
great man take that show out on the road
I'm sure a lot of tickets you're gonna
sell a lot of tickets it was a good time
I'll be there I'll buy a ticket thank
you Kim
so uh you're welcome okay thank you for
that yeah thank you Zach by the way Dan
did we get any updates on the show
tickets are we is that any developments
there uh not yet damn taking forever
we're trying to lock down I'll be the
first to hear when there's an update
we're trying to lock down a 3500 Cedar
for our end of the year live
I would love to
be there if you want me I would love
yeah I mean the last time was
phenomenal but no tomatoes well stop
with the tomatoes well then then next
year we're scoping out New York please
for summer New York please hold on
you're gonna love this
God we should do a show in New York that
would be fun but that's not what I was
going to say next summer do you guys
think we can sell it out I'm skeptical
where the Hollywood Bowl no oh oh
no are you doing a bit all right okay
not the Hollywood the Hollywood Bowl is
way bigger what's the Greek the Greek is
like 6 500. Oh you mean no the Hollywood
Bowl is like 20 000. never mind so you
would do another show next summer here
in a larger larger 6500. you ready for
that I'm ready for you you gonna bring
your A game I'm gonna bring my eight my
eight team and my a game yeah are you
serious I don't want to bring my blow up
though to that big one okay so anyway
um congratulations on a million actually
we're here to celebrate your 100
authentic real nobody even said anything
about my hairline I'm a little little
down about that well no comment is good
that means it looks really loud
Dan or Zach would I've been
complimenting you all morning thank you
very much you're welcome very much and I
will say that the hair guy who's Kevin
out in Beverly Hills whose super guy
does a lot of celebrities he had the
hairline oh he got paid how much you
paid Kevin 95 plus a tip
but he had it higher and I said I'm
gonna go lower
20 uh 30 today he was with me a long
time
he went lower because I said the guy
that he did limbo once it lower so he
went lower because of you
so it's lower I'm surprised he's willing
to do that well because you know he has
some some professional he had he used up
a lot of spray I had to order another
spray he went a little ape today I
got to tell you the truth so anyway um
we wanted to celebrate a million thank
you so much there's one million views
you want to take a picture of that Dan
you prepared something oh you actually
Danny might want to get images
you don't have to take orders from him
he's not even they want to stand up to
get it better I mean she's lazy guy you
don't have to sit down to stand up you
got to pay him man I'm gonna pay him
here it is Jimmy Lee the Jersey what is
this started from the bottom now we're
here started from the bottom now my
whole video here
video it look at this this is a one
million Danny video sub whoa look at
that thank you look guys one million
followers you see what's on the cake
Jimmy
[Music]
oh you see what's on that work with me
with the hair hairline baby
yeah come on come on and get in here get
this cake and this is home made by
Samantha
I'm gonna get a slice of that is that
okay Jimmy if I have a slice yeah I want
two slices that's just a beast man and
what an achievement really and I and I
appreciate I do want to thank all my
friends really around the world now
we're planning a UK trip next summer
like you're planning yeah we're planning
to go back to England because we shot in
England at covid and we actually did we
do a show do a venue and do like a
ticketed event well you give me the
contact information
like the people you use I know there's
companies don't you have like 20 people
team we're up to 15 now but I I've never
done that thing where you have to get a
company to do that I really have 15
people yeah and nobody knows how to book
you a venue I have more I don't have
that type of P just call them
Jimmy you just played a comedy club
yeah we played a huge comedy club in New
York I'm about huge 12 people no but
seriously you just call them and say hey
I'd like to reserve the venue for this
day so literally all they do I may have
to do it is that right Dan that's pretty
much it I mean
we would do something small obviously to
start by just saying if Jimmy wanted to
reserve a small Club he just call him
and say hey I'm gonna like the spot for
this day
uh yeah maybe Dan could give me some
guidance I've never done it yeah dude
you could you could probably even do
like a 200 seater to start something
small maybe the Four Seasons in New York
I was going to say you can do a
residency in New Jersey probably I would
do New York because I'm in New York
youth almost every week a lot now
so so anyway there it is uh we we honor
you can I ask you a question do you
understand at least why
um I think that some of those followers
might be fake or I suspect it no no you
don't understand even why I was going to
say do you want to throw up the trailer
of the of the new movie sure I actually
have questions about that yeah you don't
understand why I think some of them are
fake even a little bit well we're we're
touring now so you know now you you
maybe understand more why
[Music]
you know we're we're out and about
so here's Jimmy's uh Instagram
page
uh one million big ones congratulations
oh you're doing something with Martin I
heard yeah yep
tasting water so that's tomorrow night
and if you guys wanna he's coming back
from New York today and right Danny we
uh text him and we're gonna talk later
and we're gonna go down tomorrow night
too when's Gwen's restaurant well we
were we were right before you got here
we were texting oh you guys talking
about a Gwen we're gonna go to Gwen's
and he mentioned you've eaten there and
uh you know and he he has all the words
that's what my parents when they were oh
that's the plastic surgeon he's a very
good friend and a supporter Dr Robert
Ray Dr 90210 and what does he do very
famous place of surgeon
yeah listen to it from the beginning Dr
Robert Ray Beverly Hills plastic surgeon
and I'm a huge fan of Jimmy Lee he
doesn't know dude if he only knew what
he knows he knows
like well I can make a compilation and
ruin his career no no now you'd be nice
you'd be nice you're a fan of who you'll
be nice because Robert raised my buddy
right now were you doing work there no
he was in a uh place where we had a
pedicure and came in and uh just vibed
us and what you guys yeah we did some
photos plastic surgeon he did Dr 902
when I was like that 15 years ago he's
very famous from TV from e-channel his
hair looks Supernatural
oh Sam
can you explain to me look at this this
is this is so tasteless Jimmy why
would you post this look at this you
guys oh we got ice cream like we already
talked to you once about these Instagram
posts are you guys seeing this what is
this is so Good Sam what does this mean
hey Sam Sam what are you not going to
poison me are you okay I'm just checking
Jimmy why would you post this on 9 11.
like what is it exactly you're trying to
say about that tragic event so you'd
have to get Mason on because I didn't I
posted that but I don't know
well are you not familiar with 911 of
course I'm familiar with it but where
were you I don't know Jimmy yeah where
were you on when the powers fell I was
in my office working you have an alibi
did you finish the job or did you take
the day off no we worked that day but it
was very sad I remember that day what
are his analytics in Saudi Arabia thank
you Sam oh so what why is your face
edited like that maybe it does all that
I I don't know why seems a little
insensitive
don't you think well I'm older and I
don't understand some of the memes I
know they they dry but I don't
understand like why but I put them up
because the kid does them but I don't
quite understand them
so you posted
it's I think maybe a metaphor for your
your soul also fell that day when the
Trade Centers did is that what that's
supposed to be I think so it's like a
metaphor okay would you say that's
accurate
I honestly don't know I'm not being mean
no no is it is it accurate what about
your soul following up falling on that
that was a sad day yeah when that
happened but you bounced back real fast
from it would you say
well my wife and I had a trip planned
the end of September to go to Europe and
we postponed it one year oh you did yeah
we had a trip to last week of September
2001.
to go and we went exactly one year later
it was um Dublin Edinburgh in London was
it out of respect for the victims or
you're fear of flying around them thank
you very much yeah it was fear of flying
oh thank you very much yeah because it
was a scary time right uh thank you very
much yeah right please
it's very scary
I mean that Osama been drinking he's an
alcoholic you know that Osama been
drinking drinking oh he's an alcoholic
he's dead I think oh he is dead but he
was a heavy drinker I don't think so I
think that's against his religion Osama
been drinking drank a lot
that's the new that would be a new that
would be his caliphate or whatever the
cake is so good
thank you Sam
um well if you then I don't understand
why on Holocaust Memorial Day you posted
yourself outside Auschwitz
are we back on this stick again we're
doing this again Jimmy I'm not making
this stuff up Jimmy Lee calls you out
for running a skit into the ground he's
doing this he's doing his job what do
they call that in Yiddish
there's a term for it but we're gonna
we're gonna roll with it you pulled that
on me once before this is very
insensitive this is like a joke I would
make so this will have to be taken up
with Mason like I I would say like Jimmy
why did you post an absurd picture of
your face over the trade tellers on 911
it's just insensitive I will I will deal
with Mason later but like you posted I
mean ultimately that's your
responsibility Jimmy because it's funny
that's the reality I think that he
changed the caption too it was like
September 11th 2000 and fun or something
like that
monster what do you say he said the
original caption was September 11 2001.
now stop come off I don't know
come off it well
it wasn't a fun time I'll tell you that
it was really bad it was scary
I mean you had to wait a whole year
before here's Ryan Kavanaugh is a pig
man where's right Kevin on the left
um
oh this is a poster for the movie in the
center right there okay this is good do
you know who this is
no
so you have no idea what
is being posted to your Instagram
is that what you're saying he sends me
relevant stuff I trust him I don't know
that I don't even know damn this is so
good
Sam this is phenomenally good not good
I thought we had taught you a lesson the
last time but clearly not
about what this guy here do you know who
he is nope he's like a super famous
Civil Rights activist
yeah he's like a fair use uh Advocate I
wouldn't even be here without him so
you'd put him on a pig's body like that
it's a little bit and what's the quote
say
well it says caring for the animals it's
what I do hashtag Ryan Cavanaugh
information did it I just put it up
but does Mason give you the does Mason
give you the description too he gets me
everything and then I put the stuff up
every day he does it at night and I put
him up there you're just rubber stamping
these faces
yeah that's a lot of trust you're
putting into Mason you pay Mason right
he's the only one that gets paid he's
the only one God bless him I'm honest
again I'm like how much does he get
we're not going to go on the air with
that well okay let me ask you this then
is it his full-time job honestly works
for me full-time I'm not lying full-time
yes nice and he does videos a lot for me
like when we do you shoot Saturday he'll
do the reels I'll edit one of them he'll
do the others he's very young and he's
really good
and now we're lucky to have a filmmaker
I'd love if Dan you could pull the trail
up but Alex is so talented and creative
and he's become like a friend victim
finding my next victim is my next victim
where are you guys from your Spanish guy
he is say 29 in Spanish 29
. I gotta tell you I have a Spanish
girlfriend I took her to Philadelphia I
went to the Liberty Bell she went to
Taco Bell yo I got problems
540 flew out the window finding my next
victim is my next victim where are you
guys from your Spanish guy
you can watch the Trailways it's really
new it's really good where is it up or
down
um it's not on that you have to get on
YouTube go to Alex Novell
and that's Andrew uh he's still Italian
so you still have these kind of like
talking guys no one can tell you
hey there's no space for this in the
discussion unless they want to weaponize
like a nebulous moment
so he put an effect on it and they said
obviously for Alex one of them did that
all right let me watch that so how did
you hook up with Andrew we were very
curious how did that come to be so
there's a girl and she gave me
permission because I'm respectful and I
ask her her name's Lexi and um
she reached out to me and originally we
thought it was a prank so um when this
guy called I conferenced him with Mason
and Mason verified his voice because I
have no idea who he is but then I found
out who he was
and then they were going to meet me in
Seaside Heights but they ran behind and
we were at August
and Alex was filming uh people for the
documentary that know me so he came to
the diner so what you see in the movie
The Trailer yeah I don't know who he is
he came to me but then I found out he's
big he's big because Alex is like dude
you got to see how I mean he follows he
has on um he's a big deal YouTube he's
like you're like 2.5 million but he's a
he's very controversial because of the
sex scandal so
um we talked about that and then Alex
was hey put him in the movie
everybody knows who he is so I'm like
you're the filmmaker that's what was the
sex scandal he said that he well was
asking girls to do inappropriate sex
acts with he was and it's true that's
what Alex said so and of course I didn't
say anything to him when he's there I
mean it's not my place to be involved
with that that's not my business no so
no of course not yeah what did you say
his name was again Andrew Callahan yeah
you got it
I thought he said Andrew Kavanaugh
um and this is the first time that we've
actually
um so try to go on YouTube and type in
Alex Novell and then you'll see the
trailer all right that's the trailer I
think I want to show you guys I'm always
silly in a goof but I want to show you
guys a little more serious side to me as
a person and I think this will I mean in
terms of a documentary being a serious
film and uh telling a telling a uh
that's it right there
Jimmy Lee we did watch this already
right
probably don't well I like them
no we watched the crowd already can we
watch it one more time is it okay or no
no can I watch it on double speed no
it's two minutes
two minutes 40 seconds Jimmy this is a
live show we got to keep moving closing
may I may I no can we watch it one more
time yeah it's for a reason we'll watch
it okay
[Music]
okay all right you know what because
it's your millionth special
you're gonna be we're gonna watch it
really the real deal man no
don't watch it slow watch it regular
all right we're gonna watch every damn
thing no just put it regular
now you're being mean
all right all right but but in truth we
have just watched this entire thing like
this week perhaps on Monday even
can I just let's just do times let's do
times seven five
it's not quite as long whatever however
you want okay
that's fair right
oh that's slow no it's not
1.25 is happening
that's interesting that's fine
Olivia you think it should be faster
because there is a faster setting I feel
I think I I could go a little quicker
I get to see you because Zoomers these
days their brains work on higher
frequencies
when you think of the totality of what
the kid has it's resilience
I don't play that normal I'll play that
normal
it's just we've already watched it
obviously he's not famous right now but
my son it's a whole different ballpark
that we're in with Jimmy because it's
all about Jimmy Lee what does it mean to
be from New Jersey it's a lot of energy
a lot of fomo you have any Jersey jokes
in your mind do you know what uh
Delaware wore to the uh to the party
for New Jersey
okay now you want to get to the funny
ones South Philly is still Italian so
you still have these kind of like
talking guys it's like a time that's
where they shotgun
like they want to weaponize like a
nebulous
how long we known each other you can't
be quiet I think I'm getting Amnesia
yeah
Nathaniel they're other glasses too
oh you missed the Cipriani that was just
in there do you want me to go back and
watch it slower
[Music]
it comes in quick where did you get this
thing with this massive zipper we were
wondering from here from Melrose they
have all the originals so sick it's cool
right yeah yeah they have all the new
Styles here in your town you know what
uh Delaware wore to the uh to the party
from New Jersey
okay now you want to get to the funny
ones South Philly is still Italian
season all right
that's fine well I I just want to say
the trailer is going to tell a
compelling story about a guy who's a
professional dentist that wants to be
famous and and the struggles and
tribulations and trials through it and
he's Alex is going to try and make that
very compelling so we hopefully can sell
the film to a company that would sell it
to like Netflix or something so right I
could become mainstream that's our goal
I don't know if it's going to happen you
know that's that's our goal for the
movie make sure you reach out to Netflix
Brazil
oh they're they'll pick it up we know
Brazil people will pick up but we're
trying to get in this the states all
right here's the deal I gotta thank our
um sponsor for today and then I'm gonna
move on to some of our uh planned
material
you need to go to the bathroom yeah of
course
Jimmy's getting up to uh go to the
bathroom in the meantime
I'm gonna thank our sponsor expressvpn
thank you to express
BP
using the internet without expressvpn is
like not paying attention to the safety
demonstration while on a flight you know
most of the time it'd be fine not to pay
attention but one day when the weird
yellow Mass drop what now
what do you do it's better safe than to
be sorry we all know that every time you
connect to an uncrypt unencrypted
Network talking about cafes hotels
airports any hacker on the same network
can gain access to your personal data
passwords Financial details Etc how has
Jimmy not been hacked yet
how does Jimmy's bank account not fully
I'm too smart for that
smart for that you think so he uses
expressvpn that's how
that could be that could be it doesn't
take much technical knowledge to hack
someone listen just some cheap Hardware
is needed a smart 12 year old could do
it
that's actually true probably
12 year olds are the most dangerous
people in society
you know because they're too young to be
blamed for anything but they're just
smart enough to get to do to do some
real real damage yeah yeah yeah yeah we
need to keep our eye on 12 year olds
keep keep an eye out did you know your
data is super valuable hackers can make
up to a thousand dollars per person
selling personal info in the dark web
that fridge
anyone's gonna sell my data it'll be me
can I sell my own data for a thousand
it's more than the going rate is with
any of these other people Verizon
you know what I mean
why should you use expressvpn it's got
encrypted tunnels
you create a secure encrypted tunnel
between your device and the internet
hackers cannot steal your sensitive data
this tunnel is locked down by super
secure technology
it would take a hacker with a super
computer over a billion years to get
past expressvpn's encryption
that's a that's a long time
that's a really long time really long
time I don't even think Humanity will
exit by the time they get done probably
not I mean a billion years my goodness
um it's easy to use fire up the app and
click one button just to get and to get
protected just one button fire it up
boom Bob's your uncle and it works on
all devices phones laptops tablets and
more and you can stay secure on the go I
love expressvpn because
one is the most reputable brand it's the
easiest to use and they have the best
reputation so when it comes to securing
your data
when it comes to trying to
access content from other Geo locations
stuff like that
there's only one choice it's expressvpn
they're the best in the game and they
got a great deal for you guys secure
your online data today by visiting
expressvpn.com H3 that's expre ssvpn
dot com slash H3
and you can get an extra three months
for free guys that's expressvpn.com
H3 thank you to our wonderful sponsor
please uh consider supporting them thank
you guys thank you
oh there's should I address that Dan
sure so there's a conspiracy in chat
that this is pre-recorded
but it's possible that this statement we
knew acknowledging that is just getting
ahead of it yep we knew they would be
suspicious so we were smart yeah you
went back for another bite yeah I know
that was really good it makes like my
wife my wife when she bases really what
is your wife back she'll bake cookies
and and sometimes cakes
Lynn's a good Baker I love Lynn Lynn is
a good egg Lynn talked to Zach yesterday
and uh Zach tell Ethan what Lindsay I
had a very very nice conversation all
series inside a very nice this is that
right yeah this is like serious very
sweet why did you talk to because I was
talking to Zach and beeped in and and
what did Lynn Sadie's act tell Ethan uh
that Jimmy is more than uh honored to be
a part of everything we do for him and
he's so grateful and um she's a great
person she's just a humble nice person I
met her a long time ago and I remember
the wedding uh she said you do I said
with who and she said you and I said did
you she said you and then she she
up
oh thanks Ethan well I don't know I've
been with her many men you said it not
man many years here's you in Brazil by
the way they just carry you like a
oh so you did see the image yeah they
the fan base was so high there that we
had the Spider-Man outfit on one of the
gigs and They carried us out and the
Press there was just amazing they
treated us wonderfully all right yeah it
was so big there really huge huge pink
um here's uh actually this was on
billboards everywhere in the country I
heard yep so you saw that too yep
what does that mean that means go screw
it means yeah I I was like trabaj sounds
like work with me and that was after our
uh first TV interview and is this Christ
the Redeemer sure is and so he's saying
work with me people it's Christ The
Outlaw with those hands right
the rousing reception we got down there
was like no other I mean we never ever
had a pickup that big even when we were
in England it was big but it wasn't as
big would you go to England we went to
England during covid after 9 11. all
right guys we got to move on we gotta
move on thank you though for finding
some of the Brazil stuff we're going to
continue and then this is the James
weiner hour
I want your commentary as a um co-host
as a man as a dentist as a learned man
with family a wife
take and maybe don't make a spectacle of
yourself okay you won the series James
weiner yeah okay does James weiner wear
the chanels and doors
no so let's stop making a spectacle of
ourselves then shall we
these glasses
you don't like it do you not like how
you look without glasses you never gave
me my compliment
what on the on the face work I was just
gonna ask you you look fantastic
phenomenal better well so what what did
you get done
I'm like the whole word Olivia my
Olivia you're glowing we made we made a
trip to see somebody and uh after the
last few months combination of different
procedures to make the Jersey outlaw
you know younger than his his normal age
of 53. all right younger than that right
all right yep
what procedures did you get done Botox
filler and micro needling where'd you
put the filler I don't know so the botox
goes in expression lines like forehead
and neck and filler goes in voided areas
that are more caved in little cheekbones
and Chin you know the uh mandible the
angle the mandible down here and uh in
the zygomery with the bonus okay
fantastic and uh I feel better I used to
look at myself in the morning oh and now
I look at myself in the morning I live
and I I give one of these you give
yourself a thumbs up yeah yeah now the
hair snacks don't live so we don't have
to keep spraying on that's the next move
no I like it like this I think you look
you don't want me to go get the I mean
it definitely what do you think the
unique look I would say all right so
let's stick let's stick with the the
unique look all right let's let's move
on so burning man we talked about last
week
that uh The Burning Man the pseudo
hippie uh capitalist freaks went to
Burning Man and left all kinds of trash
so one thing they did since then is they
do this event called leave nothing
behind event where they go and
apparently pick up all the trash in the
desert okay so this is a video from
after the leave no nothing behind event
leaving no Trace leave no Trace exactly
you tell me if there's no Trace out here
you you tell me what you think the
burning man they don't want you to see
warning disgusting are they left porta
potties with and piss in it like
what that's a trace where I come from
it's all been left abandoned on the
player after the league no Trace event
wait what was that someone wrote some
there
said
we were too tired to move our
thanks Resto for taking care of us
oh cool fine awesome well apparently
they were too tired to carry your
too you bet
there is garbage left everywhere this is
literally just the beginning
here's a bag full of vomit found an
abandoned car with a tapping toilet what
is the purpose okay then let me tell you
this this is how you know that all these
Learners are just such Rich
like who do you know
they can just leave a like nice car in
the desert this is just something that
looks like abandoned car God damn it
that's like a nice ass looking what BMW
Volvo what is it Volkswagen
yep what's the purpose though of what of
all this
oh it's you know what Burning Man is no
oh Jimmy I don't know should maybe go
next year but what actually is it like
why are they this is a big Festival in
the desert it's a big party in the
middle of the day they're apparently all
these hippies and feel good people
what's it like a Woodstock yeah kind of
it was very like music more about the
drugs I feel like so to Woodstock drugs
not music
it's like a giant MDMA party in the debt
in the middle of nowhere but why did a
lot of people go oh yeah yeah it's quite
the whole thing for like what the
weekend or something I think it's like a
week long actually so what like this is
not even like an old beat up car
somebody just left their VW here like
what
somebody go steal that thing man pretty
wild
abandoned Carr with a camping toilet
this definitely looks like leave no
Trace to me meanwhile here is an
overflowing dumpster nearby experts say
these what's in the plan may take
decades to heal another car left
abandoned
is this in Las Vegas or where is it it's
in is it in Nevada uh I believe so yeah
yeah it's in the baron weird it's a
Black Rock City
Nevada
I think uh yeah that's real nice let's
look in the porta potties I'm sure
they're clean no
oh that's so nasty at least
these burn scars look environmentally
friendly yeah that's gonna heal up real
nice I don't know what's leaking out of
there but I don't want to know at least
the burners left no trace on the roads
did so I mean this is one of all
those bags what's all that eighth this
right here it's just like plastic card
water bottles so what are you saying
they go for a week and hang out in there
there's
rich people that go there pretend like
they're connecting with the Earth and
that they're like Kumbaya they need to
trash the desert they need more they do
burning man you know who's there Elon
Musk oh him he goes Burning Man the idea
is that you were burning the man right
we're just people of this world down
with the man Elon Musk was there
makes no sense whenever we talk about
burning the witch
so I'm calling an end to burning man
right here right now I agree with you I
makes no sense whatever it is thanks
buddy appreciate you the biggest an
older guy it makes just no sense
um this was a fun little anecdote from
the subreddit
um I was in my lupus era
and this person it
sometimes it being a fan of this show uh
has consequences in the real world and
uh this is one of them today I found out
my boss has lupus and I laughed in her
face
I had literally never heard of it before
the H3 episode and it was so such a
funny bit to me when she told me she was
upset and I oop
zero points people are not down
I mean that's just not that's not cool
is a very serious element do you have it
um well I might
my wife and I have it too really yeah
she's upset oh no it's bad disease it's
an autoimmune disease and it's treated
it has episodes they flare up they go
away I know everything about it this is
the um disease attacks the cells in your
body can and and hurt a lot of organs so
there is this one drug that my doctor
friend told me about I forget the name
of it but it actually helps the disease
if the disease gets more than not too
serious
and I had a patient in last week my
office who takes the drug a woman and
I'm trying to remember the name of it
you could probably Google and it would
come up and I'll remember it but um it
it helps her to pretty much stop the
progression disease really the key with
lupus is you don't want it to get severe
where it hurts organs because it can
damage your yeah
all organs it attacks your cells and
your organs so it was a drug
vocalosporin
um
no but you know something that they use
for malaria it's an anti-malarial drug
oh but it works I think I have that
too maybe the hydrochloroquine right I
think I think that's it yeah
I'm seeing that's part of Lupus
treatment as well so that's part of it
along with steroids but what I what I
was saying to you guys my Loop is air as
in retrograde if you do have anything um
you have to figure out where you're at
with it and then if the doctor will let
you know if I do have it it's very mild
right so that's what I think my wife a a
test and right so she had that too the
anybody so if um it's it's mild which I
think is weird
um you don't do anything but if it if it
moves forward and you have to get tested
is your wife okay or she ill well I'm
more upset about than her because she's
you know Asian women look like stubborn
I'm all right like she said I said Lynn
we're older you need you need you need
to see if there's any malaria drug you
need well is she is she having symptoms
or did she well she'll get she'll get
she had the positive thing and she has
to rash oh the rash did she get it on
the cheeks no she doesn't have the
butterfly that's she gets it here so
that's the what I've been going on
you're getting a butterfly rash on your
face that's Panther basically from what
I understand is if it's lupus it's going
to be on the cheeks well generally a
butterfly rash so it's here and it goes
across the bridge I talked to a uh
rheumatologist and stuff and they're
like if you're not if it's not here you
don't have Lupus because I had a rub on
my face that's not necessarily true but
right it is a path of humanic sign to
have the butterfly rash on your face but
it's not a jokey thing because should I
say another rheumatologist no I would I
would track process of the disease maybe
every six months and have your blood
twice a year I wouldn't play with it no
it's not a disease to play with right
yep and that's serious and I've studied
a little more because of my wife I was
concerned for her you know do you have
any diseases or kind of stuff I am lucky
in that uh being an older guy I go twice
a year and get blood and I'm really okay
not what I'm pre-diabetic but and uh
it's pretty thin but I guess that just
happens you know no I lost weight 10
years ago and kept it off through
portion control and I try to though I
cheated today because Sam I tried not do
fatty stuff too much and uh but I cheat
something how bad is your pre-diabetes
are you like mild or right up there real
low like the the the A1 A1C A1C 6.0 yeah
and the uh glucose goes between 105 and
150. you're gonna live forever but uh
you're one of those guys that's gonna
live I I don't do drinking or drugs and
I'm careful with my body and I I work
and sleep and I don't do bad things to
my body so knock more than less if
something crazy happens I hope I'm
around a while well anyway
um
check this out this is something that
absolutely killed me I saw this on Tick
Tock and
we weren't even sure if it was real
we had to look it up we looked it up and
it is real 100 real
um and so and this guy's my hero kind of
uh but tell me what y'all think about
this hi everyone what is your emergency
yes um I need a police officer over here
what's going on
um I've got two teenage daughters and I
just got home from work
were physically fighting with each other
and one of them kicked a hole in a door
and
um they're 12 and almost 14 and the 12
year old is completely out of control
and I I can't I physically if she's as
big as I am I can't control it okay did
you want us to come over to shoot her
one it's actually funny are you there
excuse me that's a joke
what is your name Mike Forbes Mike
Forbes
yes he can I'm sorry I apologize
because it's like this guy gets calls
all day long but you know what I mean
and he hit the wrong joke with the wrong
person well she she goes come arrest my
12 year old like what do you want the
police to do my 12 year old and 14 year
old Fighting send the police you know
they're going to break up a fight but
he's on the behave they're not going to
do anything oh I know and also the
police kill people right they just show
up and kill people yeah right I mean
kind of That's funny though
I love how he immediately walks it back
so hard he's like oh man
I up bad find that Port one more
time and
that's so wild that's so awesome
this is funny that's something Zach
would say that's uh that's our boy uh oh
man I wonder if we could get him to call
in
but yeah I saw we saw a article in the
local news it's 100 real he was not
fired he must be where was where what
city was that I don't remember it was in
Texas I'm not sure oh and then here's my
best part
10 years
[Music]
it's fun
we buttoned it out
what does that mean
it's erased that bit you just disagree
it's gone I thought it was good thank
you that was the problem
nobody wants anything controversial or
crazy yeah yeah that's why they've
talked about James weiner too far it was
too far yeah hot in Texas
here's my favorite part about this
though he goes uh
as I am I can't control her
okay did you want us to come over and
shoot her so she's shocked
understandably he only Waits a heartbeat
and he goes
[Music]
he's like he needed to make sure she she
understood the the he hit her with that
and then she she didn't take the
joke good at all now
no excuse me
so can we look into Mike forbus uh maybe
he's maybe he's still around
I'd love to contact him
there that is huh what do you guys think
I watched that like 10 times man over
the weekend or on Tuesday I'll just
dying
um we've got the milk boys we got JoJo
maybe we should hit the JoJo siwa chiwa
siwa what's her name siwa siwa siwa siwa
what is siwa what's the origin of that
siwa
where's that from oh miss you you know
Ethan Seymour fish
he owns a boat you know him
see more fish
what about him he owns a boat I didn't
know if you knew him he knew you okay
he sees more fish
that's crazy it's awful yeah it was
awful I know it's Olivia's joke Olivia
you told him that yep you gotta work on
your Material Girl
sorry I'm trying to figure out where
Seawall comes from what's up yeah me too
it's so JoJo went on Howie's podcast
September 12th which I mean it was a day
late because this is Jojo's 911. she
went on Howie's podcast to defend
Colleen Ballinger
which is core and I just love that
Howie's the one that hosted this how
he's become like he's at the center of
everything he really is just a force to
be reckoned with in the podcasting World
entertainment uh
go ahead keep going child
is that the ukulele girl
that's a good question yes this is
ukulele girl so this is the ukulele girl
and then this is her friend JoJo who
went on Howie's podcast to defend her
we don't know who this is
but I don't think she's relevant to the
story okay
so here let's follow up the clip man
and it's just a shame because now she
observes 911 now she needs to observe
912 as well me right
which is just a lot of obser observing
okay for one person in September you
know
what do you do on 9 11 Jimmy do you
wreck Do You observe are are you I
worked you were I'm being honest
You observe though when you say observe
there's sorrow and we feel bad but I
mean I went out and worked of course I
was at the most awful thing in my life
that I ever saw right excited for the
Isis thing you know which is awful but I
mean what was the nicest thing the Isis
with the killings the scientists in
general yeah the stonings and the
murdering all the people and all that
crap everything you watched a lot of
that I didn't watch the best yeah but
you hear about it you don't hear about
it as much now but I mean God you
weren't you weren't watching like the
snuff videos that they were posting I'm
for sure what is uh what is that on
about what's that laugh
about that Zach seems humored oh I meant
to tell you it's not use that I think
it's like the Isis
I don't mean the the Good Humor guy I'm
talking about the military people did it
yeah you're like Isis like you thought
you're getting a popsicle do you like
the Isis theme song did you know it
slaps really hard
what it's really good it is I never even
heard it yeah love I got it yo are you
can you play it I thought it got removed
I mean the song is this no Isis they
actually have a theme song it's it's
catchy can I ask you guys a question is
it even around anymore I never yeah
definitely got
was it Trump or Obama
that iced out ices
uh Moroccan it was broken it was well a
lot of people say about Barack but he
got Osama and he Iced Out Isis
yeah drone Barry the droner yeah Barry's
a drone I I was I brought this for you
because I know you like the um
the Tabasco yeah so this is what is that
this is like a NorCal secret I learned
about it when I went to college what is
it it's called the pepper plant it's a
table salsa and it is so fun it puts
Tabasco to shame
a lot of things do but
you like that's really vinegary you like
that yeah I'll try this do they have the
best chips or something do they have
that in your home country or now nah
nothing like that well that like that
kind of stuff now grab a chip and I want
you all to try this because it really is
phenomenal like I'd rather have the cake
if we could put it on the cake no no I'm
joking with it so uh the cake was good
yeah if you guys are looking for
I don't think it gets better than this
you know what I mean oh God
loves busting out the Lays lovey lovey I
love Meister love Meister love a phonic
Love Arena Love Arena
ah yeah here
[Music]
so anyway
yeah I bought a three pack because I was
thinking about it now I got two at home
I don't know
you got my
what do you like to eat for lunch you
hungry
I have a sandwich guy my dad was like
that sandwich turkey you guys hungry
lunch time stuff like that
I had like all what'd you have for lunch
I haven't eaten I had like a little
smoothie for breakfast I'll come down to
Pink say afterwards we'll get to walk
yeah when we're done here
what do you think Keith I can't do pinks
no I I find I I fold different flavors
all different flavors all different I
know you love them I don't want to speak
illa pinks because I know they're close
with them pinks is the spot Zach's
favorite place so he told me earlier all
right here I love show love I want to
see what he said this is the pepper
plant love go ahead
let's have love taste that it's a laze
not the best canvas uh for tasting salsa
but about the worst though kind of
neutral yeah right
yeah
yeah dude let me smell that is that
an eight plus Lobby it's so good
it's on a different level in my opinion
that's like good as hot sauce it's so
good on anything man damn thank you
because remember you mentioned this the
other day yeah I had to do it well I saw
how much you love Tabasco and I mean
you know I mean I've been loving
the all the hot sauce out here if you're
gonna melt some cheese or something on a
tortilla you put that on there forget it
forget about it right now put it
out of your mind all right JoJo siwa on
Howie let's take a listen
and if I'm wrong are you friends with
Colleen Ballinger still yeah I uh what
do you say about I've known I've known
Colleen first dude Howie's such a t
Hound I love it like when I go in there
he's like tell me about Trisha Paytas
like he knows all the teams you want to
start start up yeah he does he knows Bob
Eubanks on the newly origin game when we
were kids just like Bobby did the same
thing when we were watching what's your
favorite place to have whoopee
so yeah Howie's really learning how to
do this man how many views it got twenty
four thousand wow
is right there I'm surprised it didn't
do better actually that's probably good
for Tom Tom is doing well Tom's
actually gotten a big uh Big Boost
Thomas I've been keeping an eye on Tom
is Tom doing well in Brazil
I don't know but that could be a good I
didn't think so just ask that could be
good advice though
well I told him I told him to go gobbler
mode and he
I seen he started mentioning Goblin mode
quite a bit in his media he likes that
phrase doesn't he Tom words let's check
I'm sorry this is this is a weird
episode guys I'm sorry
but I gotta check on how strong he's
doing that right it is off the rails we
got Dr James weiner here on off the
rails so we're here who is Tom Ward
another podcast guy he's been in the
game for a long time man he he's
interviewed all the greats
and so two weeks ago he got Patrick Bet
David on 157 000 views man wow and look
at that title Patrick Bet David drops
shocking bombshell in this exclusive
interview
the shocking bombshell uh probably that
he probably that he um doesn't like
mayonnaise I don't know
oh no I didn't watch it okay probably
nothing uh Patrick Davis
then the view is kind of the you know
and now he's 700. his journey his
personal video there turning with
depression did
okay I didn't watch it but I saw lots of
love for it on the sub ready yeah
but then nobody cares about this Devon
guy who's Devin yeah nobody cares about
him from couches whatever happened to
that hockey kid when I was on last time
that was a know-it-all what was his name
hit that was uh Sebastian yeah what
happened to Sebastian I think we ended
him I think you eithered him yeah yeah I
haven't heard from him since frankly his
career is over yeah I'm glad you had
that ringside seat to that though I was
hoping to debate someone today again too
just because I really liked having you
on the yeah that was fun I really liked
having you on this uh this is the uh
this is the artist kind of oh he's an
artist and stuff
yeah the title said uh from Couchsurfing
to uh
oh I know who that is
that's uh Kodak Black is that Nipsey
Russell Nipsey Russell looks like Nipsey
Russell
sorry no not next SEA hustle Nipsey
Russell when I was a kid that's Kodak
Black Kodak Black yeah
he looked like Nipsey Russell who's it
Nipsey Russell were you talking about
hustle I I don't know Nipsey Russell
he's talking about he was a black comic
on The Dean Martin yeah Nipsey Russell
that's him right there yeah second from
the left his uh his name was a play on
this guy's name oh hey Olivia did you
know I modeled
did you know Ethan I modeled when I was
young
I didn't
I was third from the right on the
evolution chart
out there
yeah you're pretty close heard from the
right yeah you're pretty close
um all right seriously I gotta Focus now
JoJo speak uh sing like a canary you
know you understand
since I was since I was 12 red flowers
because I cut the beginning that's for
you love
thank you you're welcome reset it up
even let's just start from the beginning
yeah JoJo siwa went on Howie's podcast
to 9 11 her career on 9 12. is that good
Dan yeah thanks that's real good thank
you and then we went on a little bit of
a tangent about Tom Ward if you want to
pick that up no I don't oh we're cutting
that part let's just start over oh I'm
sorry
Dan you're not helping okay let's take
it from one then let's go back JoJo siwa
went on Howard's podcast that she 911
her career called Howie not how nobody
calls him Howard it'll be confusing I'll
take it from the top again JoJo siwa
went on Howie Mandel's podcast to 911
her career on 9 12.
now to play that Mischief music boy if
I'm wrong are you friends with Colleen
Ballinger still yeah I uh I've known
I've known Colleen
since I was since I was 12. so for those
that don't there's the problem yikes
she's a victim too
how old was Colleen when she was 12.
didn't we say 12 year olds are the most
dangerous people in the world said that
how old was she when she was 12. that's
a good question so she's 20 now I'm
seeing and eight years old Halloween
it's like oldest how is she like 39
. so Colleen would have been 28. I'm
done then he was 28. so almost a 30 year
old just chatting it up with 12 years
I'm telling you man there is nothing
to glean from a relationship with a 12
year old as an adult nothing it's crazy
you know
in the middle of a kind of a it's tough
let me ask you this JoJo did she make
you put a tampon in your mouth and send
a picture of it
[Music]
it's a Colleen what was the name of the
character Miranda also I love how
clueless how he is he just he doesn't
have any idea what's happening but he's
still good he did pretty well I agree
with the questions in this I agree yeah
yeah I agree this sings my daughter my
other daughter went to all the concerts
and everything and she's getting accused
of things yes which we don't have to
talk about that She's accused of but
I would imagine if you're friends with
her you kind of met her when you were
young I was yeah how he's doing a good
job he's following the thread very well
he's good good he's getting good
[Music]
her and um she's always been nothing but
kind to me and her family nothing but
kind to me
um she was nice to me defense love that
she's Ashton Kutch cushioning her stuff
Ashton butchering her career am I right
whatever happened to him he just put out
a letter of defense for a twice
convicted rapist
he had everything and what do you do f
everything up
and passion or the other guy Ashton
Washington the actor that was married I
mean uh what's your name Demi Moore yeah
no he's doing well did you know he was
an angel investor in Uber
no
a lot of people don't know that about
him I don't think Jimmy knows what Uber
is I take goobers in New York all the
time I do know what it is there you go
Wise Guys wise guy so there
your son's a you sons are
your son's a doc
why because I'm uh never mind all right
let's continue
yeah
I think it's really
it's the first time that I've talked
about this I just want to make sure I
say my exact piece that I want to say
this is awesome she's like I've been
defending her
I'm gonna defend her I'm gonna do it
today on Howie Mandel podcast how he
does stuff
this is Ground Zero of my career right
here Jojo
we talked about him I mentioned your
name to him by the way I wanted to thank
you I saw the um
he said the comedian that they threw the
tomatoes at you how to say that's Jimmy
Lee the Jersey out yeah respect on your
name no well you you he doesn't know me
maybe he could have you on us dude we
should try to get him on Powers could
you could you could you get me that
would be pretty fun it would be wild
with you coming with no no just you no
you too what yeah I'm sorry no but
you're the you're Jimmy Lee you're the
polo act we should we should do it all
in one dude you and Howie how do we do
that well I'll talk to him you want me
to text him right now yeah yeah because
I you guys that would be that would be
cool oh yeah I don't know Dan you got
reservations about this no he's an older
guy he would get my comedy what's your
reservation Dan
[Music]
um just subjecting uh Howard for that
don't voice Jimmy on another right yeah
I mean also I mean Jimmy I had no I
didn't tell you you're our guy I mean
that's kind of all he can say Dan is now
I'm fine you're concerned about loaning
Jimmy out to another podcast yeah yeah
yeah that's the primary I would be just
normal
you would say to do like if you said
just go on as me and let him lead how do
I pitch this to Howie where it doesn't
come off like totally crazy well you
have to say the guy that the comedian
they threw the tomatoes at when you were
at the live show he knows who I am from
he was Emily the Jersey Outlaw yeah you
just have to say the comedian from the
live show they threw tomatoes out I'm
gonna text him later because I feel like
this is a delicate okay I'm not gonna
read it yeah you better read it Howie so
if something happened with Zach or
someone let me know that would be great
yeah yeah of course wow I'm in town all
week
I'm in town till Sunday I know Monday I
leave Monday I mean I'll tell him I'll
be like listen how we are our fans will
watch it we'll probably do pretty well
oh yeah he has a million followers on
Instagram I would love to go on but I
want him to want me to be on I don't
want to go on if he doesn't want me to
be on well you won't be on if he doesn't
want you right he doesn't do things he
doesn't want correct so he'd have to
want it and then you know you you asking
him would make a difference because he
knows you yeah and he loves you that
would be mean a lot like a whole lot
okay you
um it didn't sound too good based on
that sound bite man it's taking me a
minute to get to this JoJo stuff
we should probably take it from the top
you know and it's like when you get how
we involved I love Howie so much it's
hard to even go it's hard to even speak
about him I agree with you he's such a
great guy he really is such a Class Act
yeah
basically a family friend at this point
are you really tight with him now he
hangs out with my mom talks about
butterflies really so you're like body
like butt no we're dogs like if I text
him back he gets back to me immediately
we're cool like that wow I'd be honored
he said all right let me text him hey
Howie we got this
how should I say crazy comedian is that
fair to say fun Street comedian you met
him at dh3 live let's take let's
crazy comedian you met at the live show
would you ever consider having him on
your pod crossing my fingers I think
he's got a lot of momentum he just hit a
million uh followers I think it would be
super funny and I'm sure our fans would
tune in and love it hey thank you so
much my God hey Howie we got this crazy
comedian you met at the live show Jimmy
Lee also I forgot to type your name
Jimmy Lee
this is the Howie Mandel theme song
that you're hearing Jamie Lee would you
ever consider having on your pod I think
it would be super funny and I'm sure our
fans would tune in and love it too no
pressure just thought it'd be a funny
idea you know what I mean you're doing
it where you're being nice and let him
make a call
be a funny idea thank you he's my God
that's like super nice I sent it here
you go Howie Mandel
he usually gets back to me right away
too so we'll see I mean that would be
what do you guys think what does your
crew think of that I think it'd be
Showbiz Magic
two greats coming together well him I'm
on my way up hopefully hey thank you my
God you're gonna
gee okay come here
no I'm not
I love Ethan he's very nice I mean we
have at all history it all started at
frescoes 10 years ago sure did when you
sexually assaulted our waitress and
Ethan said bring on the meats and they
brought three orders of pursuit
Department
Hiller was on a little phone filming I
had by Guy Brian filming that was a long
time ago yeah I mean even we were coming
up then too you know it was a big yeah
yeah time for all of us and uh whoever
sent that
video a few years ago when you found me
a CD oh my music they sent or no not the
one f'd up Dennis thing the one no the
first thing we saw was the one up
Dennis right right but apparently you
send it to them on a CD or something no
I was doing music before comedy you're
handing CDs to your clients gave CDs to
people when I did so that's nuts so
maybe that that's what they meant but
the one Dennis was not on a CD was on
YouTube so you were telling him to check
it out on YouTube no I would say here's
my CD I do music with Dave Ivey's a
Grammy producer in Philly and uh I wrote
them all my own songs and he got me some
good gigs because this person said that
you told them to watch that sketch oh I
may have said that I have a one after
Dennis sketch yeah the first one I think
we did was 2014. yeah then we and then
you said to me do another one because of
you I hired uh the second moment first
one was stamped the second one I hired
actors and comedians I work with doing
stand up right and I wrote the whole
script that I actually read their lines
with them before the show the one when
we did the Rocky on the street that was
the second one man such a legacy yeah
that's ten years ago why are we doing a
new one up dentist like well
where's the problem with it is the
metrics were bad for my business and it
was really
um I know how to kind of remove them
because my business advisor my operation
I said look go have fun with your comedy
separate your name from your stage name
do your street don't do that do not make
fun Dental do not make fun of your
profession do not film comedy bits in
the dental office yeah and you know when
I have a business and I have kids that
are going to go into it I have to be
logical you know as much as I I'm
fomored up the ones who want to get
famous
um
yeah I have a job that makes a living
um and I have to make sure I protect
that and I'm doing that so that's a
really natural reason it went off the
table was because of that that's a shame
though because that really was good so
the bald guy that was just a hired actor
the bald guy was the photographers we
came in dancing and and Ann said lower
that he lowered the volume instead of
lowering the radio I don't know what
what do you yeah the the guy that sits
in the chair that thinks she's like
about to get a hand job from the nurse
so that's John Paul She we did it like
he thought he was in a massage parlor
but he was in a dental office and
Natalie cerucci was a dental assistant
and he started taking his clothes off in
the chair and Natalie was just peeking
in from behind to be cute and funny and
and he's looking around and then she
never came back so he says I'm done I'm
getting out of here he was supposed to
be just a decoy that's all he was
actually taking his clothes off took his
shirt off okay yeah a little
unprofessional yeah but you saw that one
after Dennis so you saw that of course
yeah and that was a real uh hygienist no
Natalie was an actress
let's get to Jojo this poor girl she's
trying to ruin her career because we can
at least give her the timing a time and
play get back to Jojo does JoJo have a
career here I mean I'm not super
familiar with her work oh yeah oh yeah
Super Starter kids yeah super absolute
Superstar tours does music oh she's a
she's a Nickelodeon show so she actually
is a famous person yeah yeah very famous
person I know a dancer a singer what'd
she do all the above really yeah so how
how is she discovered okay so I actually
watched her get famous because I watched
Abby's Ultimate Dance Competition which
is the first reality show she was on she
was like a competitive dancer and then
people liked her so much that uh she was
brought onto Dance Moms as a regular oh
and then so it was like a reality star
turned yeah Star Story like big Ed but
the opposite yeah the two biggest people
coming out of Dance Moms were Jojo and
Maddie Ziegler
um
see I was I I mean again I don't know
much about her but she always seemed
nice and wholesome and all that I agree
but this is obviously a little
concerning
uh and we're gonna let her talk we are
gonna let her talk
okay right now
the internet should I start from the top
yeah let's take it from one
so for those that don't know Pauline is
in the middle of a kind of a it's tough
It's a Colleen what was the name of the
character Miranda Miranda Sings my
daughter my other daughter went to all
the concerts and everything and she's
getting accused of things yes which we
don't have to talk about that She's
accused of but hold on we got Howie's
responsible imagine if you're Howie
responded he says love it is that the NY
roast guy
oh yeah let's go well Howie Mandel
responded you yeah he said he says I
love it is that the NY roast guy
let's go see man next WoW here it is
that's Howie Mandel
put it on the glass be careful holding
that out of the receipts
oh God it's typing what I'm saying
he actually remembered me who remembers
you yeah the Tomato guy
let's let's cross our fingers Olivia see
if we get lost he's such a good guy I
want to live why is it it's listening to
me but I'm not I didn't click the
listening button
you see this leave me alone man oh I see
it it's actually talking it's typing as
you're talking right yeah I'm awful I'm
awful with this don't include you
can you can ask Dan he has to do it
right then then tell me how good I am
hey text Dave Ethan has a Dan that has
to do everything for him but he's
actually surprisingly very tech savvy
for um he gives off for someone who's
73. let's come out
53 I'm telling you my name
tell please
whisper it to me
stop it
no you did not
tell me your real age
do that again
don't say anything do it again
dude you're full of no I'm not
you're lying no dude you're a
liar
there's no no offense my age their age I
have not look look at my face see how
pretty I look remember he's a 90s wait
Ethan what did he say thank you Zach
what did he say are you typing he said
56.
he gave me some insight that I think he
might be telling the truth yeah me too
what yeah yeah what the no you're
not 56. I I was born the day Martin
Luther King got killed Okay Google
Google the date he got killed all right
are you inside maybe you're reincarnated
no no no no
I was born spiritually The Day The Day
The Towers fell was that that's
spiritually you born you were born
spiritually no no no Google Google
I mean if that's true then uh uh 55 56
somewhere around he's not I'm sorry no
offense
yo what are you saying you believe him
no but I'm saying the math adds up
okay but I saw
yeah
okay no I I know that but you guys you
gotta understand how funny it is he goes
uh
he goes don't tell anyone he whispers
and he starts
signaling to me 56. he's doing signals
from the Indians Jimmy show them your
driver's license I didn't bring me the
I didn't bring it I didn't bring
oh you're so full of I don't have
did you drive here yeah but it's in my
room
I'm calling the police then oh he's
calling the cops this man's driving
without a license I'm driving without a
license you have your wallet are you
gonna take me to hot pinks then I got
right here you got cash Bingo show me
Bingo you carry cash but not a license
not an ID oh my God Jimmy's got Stacks
yeah that's what that's what my man he's
got that's what Mike he knows that's my
grandfather you can't slip him a little
something he is get
tell Ethan about what's on my story on
Instagram
um tell them this is something you'll be
impressed with this is kind of random I
guess no tell him tell him tell him tell
us this is kind of like a plug for me
tell him it's something you should be
proud of it's a competition that I'm
joining uh if you guys want to go on
Jimmy story it's a link so you guys can
vote for me
and uh magazine page photo shoot with a
Kane hotter if you're if you guys are
horror fans you know him as chasing for
you so you got the bomb from a million
follower account yeah he won he went
from that's worth more than money oh it
was like tell him where you were and
where you were after we put it up it was
like 40th and then I went up to like
fourth or third place oh for real yeah
he was like I can't believe where I went
when we were coming home from dinner
it's on the Jersey it's on the it just
takes me to your Instagram it's on the
Jersey Outlet Jersey Apple TV
no I'm on your main one yeah I go to
your story
hey is it off the story Dan I'm looking
at right now cam just linked it in uh it
expired from the Jersey Outlaw TV it's
expired I see it
so you're saying this right you don't
need that's it that's it yeah but you're
horrifying picture dude so I'm
proud of him uh uh Ethan because he is
trying to get a grant so he can pursue
his passion and love yeah and he's
working really hard towards it and
that's why we don't slip him a 20. well
I'm part Jewish I'm a little tight
around here oh come on I don't like that
stereotype I've been battling that
stereotype my whole life yeah but you're
no I am a generous person in so many
ways just not in the way financially I
don't make money like guys I don't make
money doing my entertainment it's hard
to lay money in right that I'm talking
honestly as a friend but I didn't tell
him how I treat you he treats you yeah
he's really nice it's just fun for me to
hang out with him it's just fun I treat
him great fair enough let me see that
stack of cash bro you want to go out
we'll go to pick no I want to see what
you're what's your dude you've got like
a fat one
they're pulling out let the people see
no no
it's private it's private it's just a
little cash we know you're rolling deep
well wait a minute now wait a minute
you're you're telling me
a guy a guy in your position tell me I'm
wrong if I'm rolling deep what are you
well I don't well when you spit when you
spit does that catch it I mean talking
about money I mean money then if that's
what you mean that's what you're asking
no no no I mean money Jimmy you're
asking what's my net worth
no I that's not my bit but I mean you
you say I have money if I have money you
have you think I'm richer you buy a mile
really absolutely I don't know man
you've got Dentistry is a is a lucrative
field
I mean I'm doing well I'm not going to
deny that
you want 20 bucks man I'll give you let
me see
and then you're gonna get the 13 000
without having to win it ready oh is
that what he's competing for 13th out by
the way thank you you just need the
shout out to vote for you and you get it
yeah and then there's also like a scare
I think it's like scare but with
parentheses care it's like for a
foundation B plus foundation so how can
we vote for you uh you just click the
link and then you can just do like a
Facebook type vote thing or you can do
like a cash vote to donate to that
Foundation the story is gone so I don't
know if we I can repost it it's on his
it's on his main it's just not on Jersey
Outlaw TV but it's on his main page
reposted Dan to to my story of course
yeah I'll do that right now you have a
20 on you love let's yeah let's give Dan
a 20 of them this is Jewish guilts act
they're making me feel bad he's a good
kid he's here working give me two
hundred dollars you know I don't believe
in in free work person personally
Jimmy you should pay me for all I put up
with you give me something wait a minute
wait a minute in my defense timeout uh
what did I say to you driving here if I
get lucky and monetize my entertainment
care what did I say Dan he's giving me
every single penny if he blows I said
I'm not in it for money all my people
that are with me they can have the money
I have to give my wife some too I'm not
in it for money Heath I'll give it to
the to the people to work with you're
saying if you make a profit if I hit as
I did I'm not in there for money no I
understand I'm just making sure that we
say this very clearly if you start to
make a profit it goes back to them a
hundred percent of any profit that you
make will go to Mason
and my people and I give my wife some
because she takes care of my family I'm
not in there are you giving your wife
money that's you I'm happy money no I
have to give my wife money because she
does everything for the family but
that's you to get taking money you and
your wife well I have to give her but
I'm not in it for me to take money right
because you don't need my money you give
her I don't I don't know I give it to
her and she'll pay the bills and take
care of the kids I'm not doing it for
money I love this I understand Tony
Bennett had an interview he said I feel
like I never worked a day in my life
because what I did I enjoyed I would be
honored if I could do a job that I love
from my heart like you do that's an
old-timey thing to be like hey
internship for free you know what I'm
saying
Hey kid I'll give you a nickel and a
piece of bubble gum it's a hey work for
food like the signs on the parkway for
food come with me see the stars you know
what I mean
what do you think Sinatra and Rickles
did in the beginning they did the same
exact thing until they made money and
Harry going to watch her probably just
Harry Harry going to watch the bartender
the Slate Brothers help Rickles out when
he started out for nothing and when
ripples got big and hit and made money
he took them with him and paid them the
same thing haircut you're going to take
the crew with you they're going on the
top I'm going to take all these guys
with me now you and him is that you're
rich and he was a struggling artist well
they did struggle not having it but
that's because he's like I don't have
money to pay you but you do have money
to pay them my business isn't what it
was either since covered I I you know
I'm not lying about that it was great
took over right so people start what
happened people don't go to the dentist
anymore Staffing's very hard and to make
Revenue isn't as easy you know again
being honest with you it's a very tough
gig what I do now it was a lot easier uh
before covet it's all time you
understand old timey joke Zack would you
rather get let me ask you this Dan would
you rather get money for your time or to
be to sit with Jimmy at dinner I'll let
you um think about it and give me your
guess your hypothesis I think oh I know
what he would want I think you would
prefer to get paid he'd rather be paid
uh yeah I think that's correct but you
four you says no the real the real I'm
gonna feel so guilty I'm gonna have to
now pay you you know Dan after this
podcast I'm gonna have to you know the
real present is you forcing you to sit
with me for two hours it's like he's not
he never forced me to do anything but
who says no to a free meal with the
dentist you know what I mean just don't
order the lobster hey I always tell my
crew we got anything on the menu under
9.99 is yours right right right
it is the old-timey thing but in my
opinion you should pay them even just
even just a um how's the word something
just even like a um taste
a nominal I don't know I forget I'm
forgetting the word well but just a
little something Dan said something to
me and I said no problem and did we not
Dan the other day with the gays and
somebody said Dan's working for stock
options no
and the Jimmy Lee friends if I if I can
monetize the entertainment thing it's
it's all for my people yeah I'm not
selfish with money but I I it's hard to
pay money out of my business for them or
my business isn't as profitable as it
was to be a lot better like you know
minimum wage is what like 15 an hour so
you know just toss them like 30 bucks or
something
that's nothing to you right I I don't
disagree with you yeah and I'm not even
I'm not even trying to be uh
I'm not trying to come down on you
because it is an old-timey thing the
free work is kind of an old-timey thing
but these days I think people are
becoming a little more um
conscious about uh exploiting poor
pathetic desperate no I'm kidding don't
say that plus million followers
million followers Jimmy you gotta have
all those promo deals and you know
advertising just toss them a few bucks
you know what I mean heard a little
Jewish kid when they're down Zach that's
okay you're giving free put the sword
put the salt and the wounds I'm King
juice so I can do that to you I'm aware
of that you see that I heard 100
Ashkenazi I know don't piss him off
he's basically Moses I know he is
about to spread those ass cheeks
oh Jesus Christ
you're not porting the Red Sea you're
pointing your ass cheeks Zach oh boy
um does he at least get free dental work
well he if he came in he would because
that's actually he lives yeah
free dental work would be fat hookup
yeah
that shit's expensive how much it cost
for a checkup for your office
I think 195 190 what about like a teeth
cleaning or is that included that's four
bite wings and examined cleaning
190 195. that's actually not bad I think
I'm very affordable and that's like yeah
that that's actually fair I think yeah
all jokes aside Jimmy actually gave me
some really good dental advice I had a
question
um and he was very knowledgeable really
well about in The Invisible Invisalign
yeah do you recommend Invisalign I don't
think he needs it he has very minor
deviations and I don't think he needs it
I was honest with him because it's
expensive it's funny because the
orthodontist he goes to is a friend of
mine he's a DSO friend of mine from the
DSO course Gilbert snow who has several
locations in the area and he's a friend
and a super nice guy he's an older guy
and and super smart
so Gil snow ortho
and that's where Zach went
[Laughter]
that's funny you want to say his name
again
he only works in the winter time in
Oregon
right
and what did he tell you that
um that um that you know that I need
Invisalign
um but Jimmy's just like I said he has
mine do you recommend of Invisalign each
patient's different it depends what
their needs are yeah he has a small
diastema here and he's a normal
occlusion on the sides in these edged
Edge what about me I think he needs it
let me see your bite my bite is fine
it's just my heart don't bite anybody
you're a classified
normal occlusion where the top teeth go
over the lower so you're looking at
inclusion when you're looking at your
skeletal what if I just want my teeth to
look nicer so if you wanted maybe the
teeth to be they're tiny rotated like
your lateral size or number seven there
and you want them rotate a little bit
you want it perfect and you get it but
is that an Invisalign thing or something
else no it's invisaligned but you don't
need it if you want to look perfect like
like Olivia then you get it what about
you don't need it
you don't need that either it looks like
you need nothing really yeah yeah I just
don't like my teeth I think they could
look nicer when I smile you know
then you could do Invisalign but Ethan
there's nothing wrong
there's nothing wrong thanks Jimmy yeah
good guy so are you how are you what do
you call it when my teeth are lined up
good class one occlude class one class
two and class three plus three is like
Mega up Place threes like when
your lower teeth are all like this and
you got a big problem
there's a deep bite where the top teeth
are way over the lowers okay what am I
Jimmy
who who said that me Zach you're Zack
class one on post here on your edge to
edge in the front so his front teeth
meet edge to edge like that but it's
still class one class one on the sides
edge to edge in the front what's edge to
edge will cost you five there's no class
it means it's a different thing the
teeth hit the teeth is that right Zach
yeah the teeth is that a problem for you
no it's just it's more of a cosmetic he
he's right there like this sack
so his teeth hit in the front like this
instead of like that they hit like that
I think they look oh I see what you're
saying because it but it doesn't strike
me as odd when I see it no the the big
thing is that the little space between
but Jimmy says it's normal so um the
space is nothing yeah
diasma like Madonna had that yeah let me
see you again look
it's character yeah models want that you
know Tyra Banks wants in ANTM she shaved
someone's Gap bigger Tyra Banks actually
text me that she wants to secretly date
Zach but I wasn't supposed to say
anything I'm a taken man her name came
up I wanted to say that there's a bit of
age Gap these days oh what are you
looking up who's what do you think about
these two this is Jojo's tooth oh you're
doing we're doing a dental we're doing
Dental now
they look nice yeah but she's not biting
down all the way so you can't tell what
kind of bite she has but like she's her
teeth are spaced a little spaced out no
like she's her mouth is like that he's
her mouth is open a little bit right so
you can't well what's happening here
there seems to be some nothing nothing's
happening well she has a a crowded tooth
on the bottom left she actually has
veneers now after this oh she does do
you know that's become so popular people
are just we do we do a lot of veneers we
do a lot of implant replacement yeah you
good at that stuff because I'm better
with the older people are private that
spend the for the large the dentures and
the bridges and the zirconia crowns
that's what I've more do in my office
not so much the not the base bowling and
replacing
I'm better when my associate to do other
stuff because I've been in the office so
long they know me and I'm good at
certain things
you know I told my wife I would have
been very good with plastics because I
have an eye when I do a denture smile
line or Plastics or uh surgery yeah
because I have a good eye for art I'm
very good with my hands and eyes for it
so I think if I was young no one I know
I was telling my wife and kids I would
have been a plastic surgeon hands down
because I think also plastic surgeons
are getting their own shows now you
don't see dentists with their own shoes
well Robert Ray the guy that endorsed me
he had a show 15 years ago I told Dr
90210 right that's your boy with the
supernatural looking hair yeah super
nice guy
where did the video go
no
here's the link okay here let's let's
try this JoJo thing again all right
let's start from the beginning are you
and I'm just rewind someone are you
friends with Colleen Ballinger still
yeah I uh what do you say about I've
known I've known Colleen for since I was
since I was 12. so for those that don't
know Colleen is in the middle of a
here's JoJo's tooth it's tough
what was the name of the camera A1
veneers so are these veneers or like
total Replacements no they're all
veneers so veneer is just the front
right
the veneers picture a fake fingernail
over your finger so they don't have to
shave your teeth down or anything for
that they shave about two millimeters
off the front and about a millimeter
here for the sizal edge yeah and the
veneers like this and then it wraps
around the Ling wall a little bit so
it's like a j
and they cement them on so does it look
crazy if they fall off well sometimes
they pop off your cement if they pop off
and break you replace them but you can't
like be like I want to be without
veneers now because it'll look wild
what's that mean so sometimes the
veneers fall off or maybe sometimes
people don't like them so if a veneer
falls off you you resubmit it on or if
it breaks sometimes they break because
there's no metal I guess my point is
once you go veneer you can't go back
no no because your teeth are all
well you could go to a full Crown but
that's when you pull them no that's when
you just prep more tooth off the whole
tooth going because I think they I think
our teeth look great but her teeth look
nicer now than before
not my words look better I think her
teeth look great her teeth look
phenomenal don't you think that'll look
good on me
I don't think you need anything no dude
I'm being honest you have great teeth if
you want to look like a movie story but
you don't need to so how do I do the the
movie star aesthetic
you get a hairline like me over your
hair I tell the worst joke okay well you
get famous you guys are saying I have
nice teeth and I have a nice hairline
why don't why do I still look like this
then what do you mean
what is wrong with you you're fine and
you lost weight and you look good so why
are you picking on yourself I think
you're hard on yourself to be honest
you're right maybe right let's watch
JoJo maybe you're right
from the top I mean we did we went took
it from the top we've lost about an hour
uh or so let's go from the top here so
let's just reset up the segment from the
top all right what did I say well JoJo
yeah I got it JoJo siwa went on Howie
Mandel's podcast to 911 her career on
912.
right
yeah she did do that thanks all right
here we go are you and and if I'm wrong
are you friends with Colleen Ballinger
still yeah I uh he's asking the right
question I've known Colleen for he is
he's getting better at this he's really
because I was 12. so for those that
don't know Colleen is in the middle of a
kind of a
what was the name of the character
Miranda Miranda Sings my daughter my
other daughter went to all the concerts
and everything and she's getting accused
of things yes which we don't have to
talk about that She's accused of but
I would imagine if you're friends with
her you kind of met her when you were
young I was yeah I was 12 when I met her
oh she's always been what do we say
about this she was 12. right and so how
how old would Colleen have been I think
that means she was 27. oh well let me do
the math oh hey oh
oh you can go back and get our previous
day yeah no don't worry about that hey
Ozark oh here's Johnny
she was 12.
and kind to me and her family nothing
but kind to me
um I
I think it's really
it's the first time that I've talked
about this I just want to make sure I
say my mom said they think they're they
feel like they're having a bad trip
watching this episode your thoughts
I gotta hear what she said have you ever
been on acid
never did mushrooms no psychedelics
never
too late it's never too late you want to
be a rock star
laughing gas I know you've got access
you ever hit the laughing gas
I I never got into drugs and I did some
little drinking when I was like I never
got into none of that not not my thing
can I ask you I'm getting a tattoo in a
couple weeks on the show don't because
then you can never remove it when you
want to it's it's well before you say
that let me tell you why why my uh
beloved dog passed away and I'm doing it
to memorialize him I can't say no to
that but but the tattoos when you want
them off a lot of people always want my
dog I'm not going to take it off then
it's hard to get off well if you're
doing it for sure I understand yeah I'll
never regret that no
um can you imagine be like I'm over
Shredder no no no I I didn't know why
you were getting I got a new dog it's
like that I didn't know why yeah I
understand but I'm getting I'm gonna get
shots of uh lidocaine yeah that's to
numb your arm before they do it is that
going to make does that affect my mind
people were saying it can make me silly
lidocaine I don't think that anesthesia
I use plastic surgeon juice
dermatologists yeah before so I'm going
to numb you with that so when they do
the tattoo needles it doesn't hurt
because it's a five hour process it's
long right so if they numb if they numb
you then um you won't feel that's a good
idea yep
the nurse who's gonna do it it costs two
thousand dollars for it to come on the
show and do it does that seem expensive
or on to just numb you with top with the
beat she's gonna be here the whole time
how long how long she's gonna be here
five hours I guess approximately that's
a long time and what you're gonna numb
you again when it wears off yeah yeah so
honestly I mean to me five hours on this
show maybe a g a g note I think two
thousand I think two thousand's a little
steep yeah what's going on with that
I mean private nurse to come out
private nurse five hours 200 an hour to
me that's pretty good generally I mean I
you know obviously it's a different
industry but my understanding he knows
who you are five five hours that's like
that's a full day because you can't like
double book so your nurses they don't
make two G's a day doctor does but also
but how much do the shots cost
lidocaine yeah what do you think get a
case a lot he came for 45
dollars
we should hire each other
yeah why don't you just come do it would
you administer me lidocaine during this
I do it in the mouth I could pay you out
for them but it's not hard it's not in
the mouth yeah but it's not hard to do
but I'll be honest with you I would find
somebody that is don't do much of I
would find somebody there you're not you
don't do it enough not a thief I
wouldn't do it for you because I don't
know you think she's a thief
two grand is expensive for that and the
cost of the products nothing except the
cane lidocaine the pivot care we're
gonna have to grill her when she's on
the show well if you want to spend the
dude I'm kidding I'm kidding if you're
gonna spend the deuce I wouldn't Grill
it because then she may be a little more
Grill in there well I won't feel it so
joke's on her
uh people are saying uh that this is
borderline unwashable here's the here's
the operative word borderline yeah what
do you mean what's borderline because
because we're doing I'm doing a little
bit of where we don't watch the
video oh cause we keep pausing okay
let's watch the JoJo stuff I'm getting a
little kick out of it to be frank with
you guys but this is gonna be really
hard to edit though oh don't worry maybe
we should just start over and stop no
we're watching
the piece that I want to say
the internet
runs so far with it so far
that
it's
to the point where you just
can't do anything about it and so
obviously she's saying that something
was said about Colleen that was just a
hundred percent a lie and my question
for her was well what's the lie and I
guess I'm because everything is pretty
well documented at this point and very
much so
um
very much so out there
and I guess the the LIE is what that
she's a groomer because I guess it's
somewhat because people argue about the
definition of what's a groomer you know
yeah I guess if we're being charitable
to the point she's trying to make that
yeah the the because that's what Colleen
said in the video right
there yeah right she's just a loser
which that's not a crime so
being a loser is not a crime
I've ever groomed is my two Persian cats
cats although sometimes
nice a loser just a loser
but losers do sometimes commit crimes
right such as grooming those groomers
are losers they're not mutually
exclusive or the point that they all are
right so like she's pretty much what's
really crazy about this is she's like
100 dismissing everything like she's not
willing to acknowledge anything despite
the fact that they become besties when
she was 12.
12. you hang out with 12 year olds
aren't your kids well it's this Michael
Jackson story reincarnated right it's
not hard to figure it out right you just
got to read between the lines on this
Michael Jackson do you think he did it
that's not a hard one to figure out
what's a middle-aged guy doing hanging
around kids yeah exactly
against social media it's not sexual
favors I want to get social media get
famous but it's not a horrible it's not
hard to figure out you know like it's
just not rocket scientist Olivia he used
to get in bed with kids do the math
oh Michael Jackson we used to have
sleepover with kids what's the biggest
it's not a hard one to figure out thank
you Jimmy thank you very much well
whatever the girl says you already can
read between the lines the action show
not not what people say it's what they
do somebody's right right yeah I agree
100 yeah somebody said Ethan I need 2K
to pay my rent nice try already paid
someone two thousand to and to absolve
my guilt and now I don't feel bad maybe
next time I waste money on something
dumb I'll pay one of you guys again no
call me and ask me my opinion and I'll
I'll be honest or have Zach call me can
I get you on the phone with the nurse to
negotiate yeah awesome absolutely when's
when is it when's that tattoo podcast uh
two weeks from what day is it of the
week Wednesday Wednesday is good for me
Monday's the only tough day wait so what
so you're gonna come out what does that
mean no no you're saying you just hop on
the phone and negotiate you want to
negotiate the price
I'm going to say listen I'm in a medical
dental field drop drop it down a g note
here's the conversation as it took place
I was talking to my tattoo artist
I said do you have someone that can do
lidocaine he laughed at me he said LOL
we do have a nurse that can do it it's
two thousand dollars
that's that's totally ridiculous you're
not offended by the fact or you're not
like the honest physiologist he laughed
at you the anesthesiologist upper arm is
not painful the anesthesiologist when
you get plastic surgery get a facelift
they charge twenty seven hundred dollars
how does a whole facelift for five hours
being in the war monitoring how's that
girl
I didn't get a face oh you didn't get
the but how does a girl come out into a
2000 to do local honest team during your
arm and hang out a few hours you know
what you know I'm right should I push
back on this price well am I being am I
a chump I I think you're a little bit of
a chump on this one how much is the
tattoo guy charging right yeah
over two or three grand the two thousand
it is it well they're really they're
good they went to like really high-end
Fidel Dr Fidel's girlfriend does tattoos
she's really good um it is uh really
good
Dr Fidel uh girlfriend retro Brit Brit
does them
um she's really good she showed me her
tattoo I think it's like 2300 or
something that that's fair how big of a
tattoo it's a big photorealistic tattoo
and these guys are really good so the
pressure on your tattoos right it's the
anesthesia that's too much and it's not
him ripping me off because he said just
send it straight to their Zell so it's
not like you've been passing his hands
Jacques being King you can negotiate the
price and then call me and I'll finalize
and put the stamp on it
2ks a lot what do you think Zaki
we could use the extra G for Craig's
that night Zach sure
hey this is an important message
actually High foot soldiers I wanted to
Super Chat to remind everyone to check
twice for motorcycles my good friend
passed this Monday and a hit and run and
I wanted to remind everyone to please
drive safely
I'm a good PSA very good you say sorry
for your loss Ally it's dangerous out
there
anyway sorry about your loss JoJo of
your career uh
how did that happen to me
and I
I know Colleen very very very well and I
think that Colleen has done for for the
internet this is like I don't know what
is going on in people's brains when they
do this it's literally what Ashton
Kutcher
butcher
like butcher he goes listen I know Danny
was convicted and found guilty of raping
two people but he was really nice to me
that's what she's doing yeah right she's
like I know her and she's awesome she's
like her she likes her that doesn't mean
but she didn't do it but it's so
absurdly dumb thing to say yes it
to be honest I mean obviously the
degrees of severity of the uh uh
behavior that we're talking about are
different between the two however
um Ashton didn't like directly uh he
never
questioned his guilt right no well he
had already been found guilt JoJo's
saying these are lies they're lies
that's like actually refuting the
accusation Ashton actually didn't do
that he just like you said said oh well
he was nice to me though right true so
she's right you're right you're right
the degree of the of what's happened and
is obviously much more severe in Danny
Masterson's case but it's so wild then
even more wild that she's willing to be
like these people are lying yes they're
all lying the fact she's saying they're
lying she's in Colleen's Circle so it
means that the discourse happening is
that there's all saying these are Lies
when like literally she has admitted at
the very least to apologizing to Trisha
for or uh admitting news yes she has
admitted to that so it's like what
exactly are you saying is a lie because
we've had a lot of substantial evidence
what about like the freaking tampons in
the mouth and all this weird yeah
it's a lot of a lot of stuff
it's pretty weird just to go out there
and be like
I'm gonna just you know did she get this
grenade for no reason did she go to jail
or anything this Colleen lady no just
internet although she probably has
committed crimes is it just on the
internet story and that's it her brother
was a straight up like pedophile though
no no well in my opinion based on the
text messages he was trying to pick up a
12 year old
uh he's trying to pick up a 12 year old
or how old I don't remember the exact
age but it was very 14. I say way to
their board that's at 13.
don't I'll message myself
no I know I'm just saying
because technically they're adults at
13. no I'm just be I throw a little I
want that back no it's a Jewish
curveballs I gave it to me it's a slide
or whatever you want to call it it's
like you slide into the DMS right into
the dmers
inappropriate Jimmy come on strike one
come on
don't push don't push please
I think for Zach's sleeping in the back
there hey hey Zach wake up sucky
good bar mitzvah time to do your
proportion hey Zach's done he's had
enough of me did you do a tour person
Jimmy yeah I gotta do you remember what
it was no me neither
there's bar Mitchell a long time ago you
really don't you don't remember anything
about 60 years ago
but this no not that long shut up 60
years ago oh you guys really hate me no
I don't dude I obviously love you I mean
listen let me check if how he responded
to me
Jimmy was 1984 a special year for you at
all is that any significance 80 what
year 1984. what happened in 1984 did you
graduate anywhere
yeah I did yeah in 84. yeah you
graduated in 84. yeah
so you graduated from medical school and
went in 84. yep so when do you usually
typically graduate from medical school
like right 20s around 30 yeah around 30.
and so basically skipped so basically
I'm okay so yeah you're about 70. 84 is
when Jimmy became a doctor
I skipped because well because you
according to your birthday I mean you
skipped
I've escaped death of MLK Jr was in
1960. I don't know where you got where
you got but wait if Jimmy I don't know
where you got it wait if you're 66 Jimmy
and then you graduate 1984 94. okay
he graduated in 94. graduated from 1990.
so you're 90. so you're in your mid 60s
because I was going to say you would
have not Jimmy you would have graduated
from medical school why do you need to
lie about your age
that man is 55. take a look what am I
looking at Jimmy don't lie about your
age Olivia knows my age
you're in your 60s
why do you care it's okay it's okay to
Grace well we're gonna talk we're gonna
talk one night privately about the age
thing we're going to talk about you
there is more to say about it well we're
gonna talk about JoJo siwa right now all
right good idea that's what people want
that's what they want thank you Olivia
for that people want Jojo but it is 94.
the graduating 94. just to confirm so
then I'm 38 I was born in 85. so then if
you were 30 when you graduated then I
was oh no twenties when I graduated in
94 from dental school so you'd be like
early 60s mid 50s mid late 50s
late 60s
he's back on the 60s again he's killing
me who had a number one hit the year you
were born
was it Elvis was it I think it was
Beethoven
now that's just nice
500 years old that's just not nice all
right let's watch JoJo all right can we
watch JoJo I'm a little lost
I think we should stop we're not
restarting roll it back back 30 already
incredible Miranda Sings the character
is a comedian and I think that it's very
hard to be a character where people are
also looking at you as you're a real
human behind that character this is such
an insane take it's really I just think
it's so funny because before it happened
she was like let me just like because I
really just want to say my piece and
then proceeds to say literally nothing
please pick my words as carefully as
possible the accusers
a bunch of liars
um
she goes she's just a comedian but like
we're talking about private right we're
talking about something different
something really different Dan
what's up Dan we're doing a private
session here
get me doing a photo shoot hey do this
he doesn't pay you Dan you don't have to
listen
you got him give me give me one of these
this is Jimmy show sorry Jojo
that's going on a million followers do
you get a good one down
you got a good one Dan
really good
just good enough or stop stop stop stop
it Zach you're right you're right we got
to stay focused kazoo
thank you
all right whatever she's talking about
yeah um
I think she's just a comedian
and so she's trying to be like
I made everybody put tampons in their
mouth for a group photo because it was
funny
my brother was doing a gag
when he was trying to hook up with a 12
year old that I feel it sounds like
she's just narrowing down the possible
controversy to like
jokes Miranda would make on stage oh so
what is then she referring to like the
the one where she's probably the fart
joke
the girl who she came up on stage and
spread her legs I think that's probably
what she's referring to and then like
just is not addressing but can we admit
that that was in poor taste joke
yeah oh yeah well every Point JoJo is
about to make is wrong in my opinion
just a fact Jojo's Bizarre cancellation
nice
you steal that from someone and I think
being a guy right off the Dome nice
maybe I read it in chat yesterday I
think I remember you saying it yesterday
yeah I may have read it in chat
yesterday I don't remember I'm not
trying to steal I'm not trying to settle
into my trap go back into y'all let's
speed do credit where credits do go back
into the members live let's give full
credit to whoever said that joke I'm
gonna find it scrub through the Live
card because you were able to do things
years ago that
were okay and now that we've grown and
we've matured we've realized that
they're not okay you know you know we've
go ahead
I can't help but wonder if like she is
subconsciously talking about like these
children have now grown up and we
realize it's wrong because Miranda
Miranda Sings happened entirely when
Colleen was an adult Colleen has always
been old enough to know better but
JoJo's referencing the people who have
been able to grow into the knowledge
that Miranda is bad but she's saying
like we've all gotten older and like
grown
it struck me now it was Mega awesome
nerd I'm sorry Olivia
King wavery that was his job
and also
basically I feel like this point could
be made about some people like Jimmy for
example back in the day
people didn't say anything this was
considered uh you know socially
acceptable but you go back now and look
back on some of the stuff and then you
want to blame judge them by the uh
by the uh uh Norms of today for
something that happened 30 years ago
that is not one of these cases
right that is not it opening a girl's
legs on stage was always kind of a bad
thing a bad weird thing to do
sorry Avery I'm gonna have to I owe you
for that one could be between your legs
thank you JoJo what else you know what I
mean um but you as somebody who's been
in the public eye for a long time
do you think that
um it is appropriate to communicate
openly with everybody that reaches out
to you no good question by Howie hey
first of all it's a great follow-up
question he should have closed it up by
saying like 12 year old specifically is
it normal to be chatting with kids
having like an ongoing dialogue with
children like that you know no deal
let's see what you have to say about
that Jojo
don't think that communicating
with
fans although she's like he's like do
you think it's normal for celebrities to
uh stay in constant contact with their
children fans she's like let me pick my
words carefully
you got to be careful to not and that's
what I'm saying do not blur a friend fan
line it's very tough and here's here's
my question to you regardless of uh
judging whatever specifically is being
said that was happening
and I'm just saying this is a parent
again you said you started communicating
her with her when you were 12. yes is
that is
yes
you know he's he just hit it there he's
a good and he's a good interviewer but
and this is something that I I used to
have a problem with when I started
it's like he can't close that he can't
close the deal he's so close to being
like do you was it not appropriate that
you as a 12 year old were friends with
her he goes right up to saying it you
know what he's saying but he doesn't
drop the hammer do you know what I mean
this is a friendly interview though but
no but just it doesn't have to be
unfriendly but just say it just say it
you know what I mean so that they don't
have any room to escape the question so
Joe but he did great I'm not even trying
to take anything away from Maui he did
great here he really did you guys were
making videos and stuff together so we
actually met because on Dance Moms you
know Todrick Hall yes so on Dance Moms
Todrick Hall had a a party and invited
The Dance Moms cast and adult girls four
of the girls went and they discluded
myself and Nia it was another girl on
the show
and we all knew Todrick so we were fine
with that but then Colleen as Miranda
surprised the girls and me and Nia were
devastated because we were massive fans
and we we loved Colleen and we loved
Miranda and then when the episode came
out Colleen saw how upset me and Neil
were
and she reached out to Holly and was
like I would love to like make this up
to you guys she was like I was wondering
where Jojo and Neo were like I'm I had
no idea that this was the case like
please like whatever you guys want like
I just want to make the kids happy like
I just want Jojo Nia to not be sad
anymore and so we ended up going to
dinner
um with Colleen and it was me and my mom
and Nia and Holly and Colleen was
telling me that night about YouTube and
how her whole family did it and how it
was awesome and she Vlogs oh yeah what
about her brother he's pretty cool with
YouTube you want to do you want to chat
with him he's actually really cool he
loves chatting the kids
let me hook you up with my brother he's
really great person to just you know
lean on
mm-hmm
thanks JoJo Life that night is when I
went home and I made my YouTube channel
and decided that that was going to be my
career essentially and um that's a
wonderful sweet appropriate story yes
how are how is it for you now being her
friend and reading some of what we read
do you think it's all a lie do you think
Howie what another Banger let's put
let's make her you know let's get her on
the record
like have you talked to her there have
been a lot of people on the internet who
have
you couldn't even go to the bathroom go
ahead Jimmy
is that a old age thing with a small
bladder yeah
early 70s
oh he says even when I was younger I
peed a lot
she's such a character oh man he's one
of a kind that Jimmy yes he walked by me
touched me on the shoulder and said the
IP a lot he's the best
gotten hit with this cancellation
and a lot of them I know some of them I
don't know and I look at it okay hold on
I gotta go back this is important Jimmy
Jimmy uh distracted me with the p
Barrack
I think how he had a really good
question here that I think uh says a lot
this is a parent again you said you
started communicating her with her when
you go back too far yes is that is it
you want so we go on Dance
because we when the children like so we
had Ollie how are how is it for you now
being her friend and reading some of
what we read do you think it's all a lie
do you think it's
like have you talked to her there have
been a lot of people on the internet who
have gotten
hit with this cancellation okay so so
she says this people are getting hit
with this cancellation what is she
saying she's not being specific what's
the population so at first I was like
maybe she means like
overall internet insane cancellations
but I think she means like individually
people in the Ballinger troop no I think
she's talking about Shane Shane James
and James Charles yeah because they were
all accused of groomer being rumors oh
you think that she's umbrella she's
saying people just be people are just
accusing I want to be in groomers online
yeah hung out with both of them right
yeah
but like she's so she won't say it yeah
she's close with like all of the
Ballinger Family she would do videos
with like the family channels with
Rachel and her sister I don't well Trent
wasn't a content creator I don't know if
I'm sure she was that close she was very
very close with Trent no no no no with
the Ballinger Family so I assume they
met bro I gotta
because he's like
we've seen the DMs
and a lot of them I know some of them I
don't know and I look at it and I see
that
go on this is a sensitive subject some
oh what a good observation JoJo that is
you know what that's true let me say
this I want to give this my full
attention and word everything carefully
this is a very sensitive topic so what I
want to say is this
them be lying yeah literally
I don't understand
the point of doing this in the first
because she must have known
that doing going on this show and going
against literally the entire court of
public opinion I think she's so
sheltered potentially like she talks
with people almost exclusively that are
like you're so right about Colleen and
so I think she maybe expected some
people to get angry but some people
would be like finally somebody's saying
it she needs to open Twitter I think she
expected a little bit of that
somebody
who is affected by
any sort of any any anything anything
having to do with adults and and
I mean I I think she knows she's
already she's like do we have a button
can we go back well this wasn't live she
could easily ask her who it wasn't can
we just checked this out yeah she that
ruined her career it just happened it
just happened
you don't know it just makes her look
bad really bad yeah I don't think it I
think I don't know anything about her
career frankly I think something should
be said that we haven't said yet about
the situation too I guess we mentioned
it a little bit at the beginning but I
mean we don't know the extent of their
relationship necessarily and they
calling started talking to her when she
was 12. she's still very young she
very she may just feel an overwhelming
loyalty to somebody that helped her
career and and and everything and
hasn't yet processed the fact that that
was kind of up because you kind
of you hear the cognitive dissonance
coming out at certain points she she
made the point it's just like oh maybe
that isn't what how did she word it she
said this isn't appropriate for like
adult stuff yeah relationships like kids
and that's when Howie was like well you
talked to her when you were 12. and I I
don't think she's really fully processed
that yet it's like maybe that was kind
of inappropriate you know what she um
you're right that's a good that is good
to remember because she you said she's
only 20. she's only 20 now she's only 20
now when she's 12. this girl's just 20.
she's only 20 years old how old's the
girl Colleen that's drunk pulling down
it's like 36 37. she's a lot older yes
quite a bit older Colleen's 36. he's old
as older than me
laughs
by the way 25 don't don't I'm 38 okay so
if you think I'm 25 then we'll do the
math you say 56
25 is a 13-year difference from my
actual age
so that puts you at
late 60s
so far off
uh
yeah that's a good point honestly maybe
I'm being too harsh on her given her age
it's easy to forget because she's been
on the internet for so damn long right
and I mean it's correct and fine to call
out I mean that's crazy that she's
saying that they're Liars like that is
that is a crazy thing to and for her to
throw out there I I don't disagree on
that I think you think I think it's a
good point to to bear in mind you're
right
it's for real grooming is it's a very
sensitive thing
so then this is another thing I guess
that people get caught up real grooming
yeah I think that really exposes what
she thinks this is just like exactly it
wasn't grooming in her opinion she's
playing this semantical game where
grooming is like you know when you
prepare a child to be essayed which I
mean which is that's what the brother
was doing which is what the brother was
doing I mean unquestionably so like you
can like maybe you can quibble of what
Colleen did was grooming 100 or not but
like not with the brother no
and so but like okay even if you don't
want to use the word grooming let's just
let's not use that word then let's talk
about what she did do it's just you know
we're being silly here where it's not
about semantics
you must have young really young people
reaching out to you now well she's 20. I
mean I do and uh it's funny like I
realized when I when I hit 18 I was like
oh this is different now like wow
good for I'm really happy that you were
able to see you figured something out
that's the question
18. right yeah she had like learning as
she goes this girl but she's still young
right she's learning as she goes that's
learning as she goes but she's 20. she's
impressionable and young she's got a
long way to go she's not as smart as
that's Sebastian guy part of that guy
yeah 24 going on 90. you make a good
point Jimmy yeah absolutely it's true
because right you know you're a joke
you're young and you're dumb and I was
like I need to be very careful about
this like I know like your daughter's
nine yeah if she could right now and she
watches you and talk to you
and she wouldn't I feel that very good
interview by the way no I'm 38 how old
is he yeah but you've been on you've
been on it longer than him but he's very
good within eight questions yeah how old
is he 67. yeah dude he's like wow 30
years older than me yeah dude I feel I'm
being groomed by Howie is that not funny
uh you probably shouldn't joke about it
when we're in the middle of a
conversation about maybe I'm just maybe
what I'm trying to do is just
acknowledge the semantical silliness I
see yeah yeah that's that's fair I
understand yeah thank you Howie I love
you not a groomer just to be clear about
that yeah just a loser no you're not a
loser either we love you Howie we love
you hold on hold on hold on I'm the
number one Howie fan Howie is how old
67. okay now Jimmy is how old
you know 55. okay or 56 yeah
you and I already show us
she loves to be your friend and love to
be online and I'm sure you want to reach
out to your fans and be like hey and
give that back to them since they're
such a big hands of you the difference
with Colleen and I is we were once yeah
I became her friend and she became my
friend she became somebody let me go
back what did she the thing about
Colleen is she became my friend and I
became her friend right even though I
was way under anything but in her case
it was okay
it's just like
Olivia you know what I think to cut to
the chase
they were buddies what that woman did
she did I don't think she did nothing to
her and she's just being nice because
she likes her that's I'm listening and
watching I think that's really all that
is now I'm gonna I don't think he's the
feather I just think she likes her she's
being nice because the girl was nicer
when she was a kid
when they're well yeah when she was a
kid kid when she was 12. that's all
that's what it sounds it's giving me
like and I know this is an extreme
example
it's giving me uh
chilly Willies jeebies
what was his name the English guy
oh Jimmy Savo give me more no no no no
no no give me a provocative Dr Long John
the guy he does like he sells like
Bibles on infomercials now
you know who I'm talking about Dr Long
John the guy that lives Jimmy's Milo
yiannopoulos yeah yeah Milo oh Milo he
was on when he went on Joe Rogan
can I continue with this story or no
this is probably a terrible comparison
to me I I don't know exactly where
you're going but I have a very bad
feeling well it's like it's like a
victim trying to rationalize what
happened to them essentially I feel that
she was subject to an inappropriate like
the degrees of very different very very
very very very very very very different
I should be careful about that but it's
the uh it's the uh well what's annoying
is that she's reducing like talking
saying that Colleen wasn't that bad okay
whatever maybe it wasn't the literal
definition of grooming that we all use
it for usually but James Charles is the
literal definition
and she's doing videos with him actually
what's her defense there talk about the
makeup guy it's all all of it falls
it's it's just like none of it can be
defended I feel like it's it's silly
that she chose to go on this podcast in
my opinion well I I agree with that yeah
she's right well she I don't think you
Jimmy
a regular I mean your corner Olivia
I know it I know that's my that's my
loyal girl my buddy over there yeah yeah
we're always in your corner girl always
in your corner girl Olivia Loops is it
Loops or loops
you know that
girl I knew that yeah you knew that
but yes I don't know
but yeah it was silly for her to go on
the spot I think Ethan you coming to
Craig's tonight
uh I shouldn't talk about where you're
going Jimmy no why because you just said
that you're doing that all the time you
should go somewhere else now he's doing
your own version no I'm not doing it on
purpose without the button why would it
hit the button because you don't want
people to know where you're gonna be
dude all right we're not maybe you do
maybe we're not going the correct we're
not going to tell anybody maybe you do
maybe you you want people to meet you
there your whole thing is different fomo
I'll be at Craig's phone no I won't be
there I won't be there exactly and Dan
will be there Zach getting that Lobster
that Lobster steak dinner Lobster
chicken porn Stick it to the Man dude
if my name is Olivia kids menu
right for for Danny you just bro stick
to the butter noodles
I'll eat off the kids menu all right
then you're coming out sometimes the kid
menu slaps always see y'all at Craigs
we'll pick you up in the rolls
I'm just saying this
just so everybody knows nobody from this
crew will be at Craig's except for Zach
but not Zach but Jimmy will be there
Danny and potentially Dan Jimmy Danny
and a bunch of Brazilians but they don't
know what you look like dancers
we never showed your face yeah
yeah bingo
ah where were we
you know you're you're and you're dumb
and I was like I need to be very careful
about this like I know like her
daughter's not yeah if she could right
now and she'd watch you and talk to you
like she would and she would love to be
your friend and love to be such a good
point yeah such a good point because he
says everything idolize the the Stars
yep and it's up to the adult to make
sure that you do it right there's a
correct barrier there yeah online and
I'm sure you want to reach out to your
fans and be like hey and give that back
to them since they're such a chance of
you the difference with Colleen and I is
we were once I became her friend and she
became my friend and she became somebody
that I looked up to she became somebody
that I idolized she became somebody that
I was like wow this person is a hard
worker she's a g but like she's just
being silly because it's like my
friendship as a 12 year old with this
grown ass woman was special
so I told you like what I said yeah
Special now she
bonded with her when she was
impressionable young the girl was nice
to her so she's that's how she feels she
has to stand by her I'm not saying what
she did right but she has to stand by
her because that's she's loyal to her no
it's crazy
um is it true that Michael Jackson had
alarms set along the corridor to his
bedroom so he could hear people coming
yes he had alarms yes that I that I know
I heard that in fact Danny that's pretty
weird man personally
that's a weird one
not weird
that's crazy that he did that
he had problems Michael Jackson oh yeah
major problem dude I thought you got
problems Jimmy oh I got problems I got a
problem Oh I have problems but he had
real problems
I mean and he was like viciously abused
by his dad so like correct it's always a
horrible cycle of trump my father was a
bad yeah not the mother the father I
actually I think the mother was like
deep my theory with Michael Jackson is
that he is
he's a victim okay or bisexual oh he was
gay and I was watching this Louis
Thoreau documentary with his dad which
was very interesting and he was saying
his mom would have disowned him if he
ever came out as gay
like the mom was like brutally viciously
homophobic he grew up in a really bad
family the father just pushed him to do
entertainment yeah that's really what
what happened just since they were real
little
he got paid though you know what I
mean
yeah I made it talk talk about money
well you started when they were so young
they were on like Ed Sullivan back in
the day years ago what a talented guy
though huh he was he was really good
Michael Jackson man he died too young he
died what 10 years ago
it's got to be 10 years maybe more not
at a 56.
he died when at the age of 56. yeah but
what year did he die like then he died
10 years ago it was like 28 2011 I think
it was over 10 years ago it's been a
while he died a long time ago poor guy
how old were you when he died
how old was who how old were you when he
died
how well when did he die what year uh
2009 so how old was I I don't know I
don't know 40s
you tell me I'm sorry Michael Jackson
was 50 when he died 51. all right God
damn it let's watch
son's a Zach
that Louis Thoreau documentary with his
dad is really really uh Illuminating it
really is something interest very
interesting I'd watch
thanks yes she's a very strong YouTuber
and I I idolized that you know and so
throughout I mean throughout our country
you and everybody else that's reaching
out to her we've probably filmed a
hundred videos together and
it's she's cool that that actually is
significant their relationship may have
been very very different probably was
very very different than what was going
on in the uh was the name of her weirdo
the weenie chats or whatever
yeah no they had a professional
relationship no no no no no uh JoJo was
in those chats oh she was yeah oh that
came out that she was what okay
that's different yeah I was just gonna I
was gonna say she was outside of all of
that because she had like a professional
relationship with her even as a kid you
can be you can do both
absolutely yeah yeah but yeah we're
almost done and then we'll we'll look
there's more details here this is like
the long bro this is crazy this has been
like 10 minutes that it's taken us like
three hours yeah and by the way I know
we started late today but you gotta go
soon right I gotta I but I know I'm late
and I just feel bad so I want to go to 5
30.
okay well we got 17 minutes to wrap this
up and how long have we been live
uh two hours 45. so I want to do at
least three hours three hours yeah and
then we'll go down to eight and then
we'll go down to Craig's yeah you come
Ethan I'm going to Greg's I'm go I don't
know about Craig I with Greg Greg's
cruel too but the food isn't as good no
they don't have the gefilte fish for
that in the bagel that's 100 that's
anti-semitic what's that right bro
you're 100 that's the anti-semitic Jimmy
you're telling you they don't have what
you want you're inferior jeez to my
Judaism Zach is really very very
sensitive today it has a lot of attitude
today yeah you have a lot of attitude
data dude you're doing the computer work
you've got a lot of data you don't have
your high horse get off your high horse
Zach jump
get off your motherboard get off your
motherboard Zach I don't even hear a uh
work with me sound bite today
right yeah that's that's Bush League
he's just getting lazier all right we
actually let's focus in let's focus in
Focus then they're hitting us with the
uh they're hitting us with the um
kinetic sand yeah the kinetic sand we
got to move on we got to move on
[Music]
what's that what's that what's that
don't get me started what's that that's
the that's what they do when we're so
boring that people need other to
focus oh we'll get get get get
interesting uh oh
please
all right
all right problem is the internet Joe
Joe was able to capitalize off of
her her cancellation and they still are
and they still are continuing to and Joe
Joe because I'm making content doesn't
mean it ain't true girl bingo
just cause you're paranoid doesn't mean
they're not after you that's it that's
it that's it you're Lorna from Howie
that's it from the best you didn't even
mention my hairline
you mentioned that I didn't mention your
hairline we wouldn't want to offend
Howie would we
actually it's a little scuffed up here
mine is a little messed up oh Liv don't
you think about coming over right now
the last time was a Harry Canary all
right all right all right all right all
right it's not okay because a lot of it
is based off of lies and it's well it is
a scary it's a scary place when you put
yourself it was one thing you know I I
came to television which is
totally different and I'm new to the
internet and I kind of found it through
the kids but it is really
it's like a Minefield it is okay all
right so there's that now there's some
other
um
uh uh complementary information here
that we're going to talk about here's an
above Jojo and Ballinger through the
years to get an idea of the scope of the
relationship so this is is this her when
she was 12 how old is she
um I don't know very young if she was
12. but she was very young in that photo
I love JoJo siwa goodbye
that was a video on Colleen's Channel
where she gave JoJo a makeover who's
that guy who's this that's Chris
Ballinger uh her brother who has the
Family Channel well I mean is that the
one that you said no no that's the
difference that's why I asked because it
looked different brother but it's the
brother but a different brother not the
pedal guy yeah
um here they are Dave and Busters okay
having a good time yeah lovely playing
games they're doing silly videos what is
that together looks like a slime a slime
sit in slime I have a lot of those at my
house these days I like that
Theodore loves slime beautiful beautiful
um
Howie asked JoJo for her take when we
watched that Adam McIntyre is not happy
about this eh no he is the same age as
JoJo which is interesting because they
had kind of parallel uh somewhat
I wouldn't say parallel but they were
experiencing her influence at the same
age in the same time Adam said JoJo siwa
who calling banjo befriended when she
was a minor
minor doesn't even say it 12 12. like a
hell of minor they're saying just double
digits yeah right
not even a teenager no uh is saying
Colleen ballon uh befriended kids is all
based on lies I mean that's a fair point
right
it's it's a an irony that she on one
hand
um acknowledged but also dismissed
which is as you said a bit of cognitive
dissidents that are going on
um Adam continues
Adam the Mac McIntyre
K the knife yeah I don't know why Mackie
the knife apparently JoJo's been
collabing recently
uh I don't know when these photos took
place but with James Charles now this
man is a predator and there's really no
he's a problem there's like no other way
I saw him at uh Bella
last year you did but it wasn't very
nice my son recognized him and uh we
asked for a picture and he and he wasn't
very nice and he just left when he was
done you're lucky he didn't try to yeah
and then Colby kind of told me about him
and I said good let's just not even go
to go there that would have been a
pretty weird photo man of you and James
I think I'll put a post on the subreddit
of all time he's a lemon drop James
Charles
don't what do you say what I think he's
a lemon drop
what a lemon drop is what's a lemon
juice you know what a cootie limo is
this some old time race or uh like
bigotry that you're down homophobia no
gay yeah it's good yeah it's all-time
homophobia yeah
oh that's an old say that's like a lemon
drop I've never heard that I've heard
that before for some reason I know what
he meant but it sounds derogatory no
it's my father would call him lemon
juice I think it's prop it's safe to say
we shouldn't say it right that's some
old-timey homophobia yeah what's the
other yeah what's the other one Lightner
loafers
yeah that's that's some old-time
homophobia
they're not all light in the loafer some
of those bears would destroy you I don't
yeah they would grind you into sand
maybe I've heard it because you can
reset it on the show before
did I say it before I don't even
remember saying that but after lemon
drop you said something else light
lighten their loafers you said something
else uh cootie lemel what is that I
think that's Yiddish cootie lemon cootie
lemon I don't know what that means
that really bad I have no idea it's
Gotta Be what language is Zach would say
their old time sayings no old time
homophobia that good old time yeah you
know how it is a little old-timey
homophobic what are they saying to
Sopranos when they killed that one guy
that was gay they call them no the Lions
call them what do they call them yeah I
know we can't say that no but it's it's
a derogatory yeah you actually don't
know I should come up the Italian word
but I don't think that the mobster is
killing I mean that would be a
homophobic remark I would assume if a
mobster killed them and then used that
derogative oh they have a derogatory uh
name for a gay guy and they killed one
guy on the show Sopranos because he was
a guy you're a heavyset guy just because
he was that homophobic
well when you say homophobic what does
that what do you mean by that like uh
well you know like right like
not racist it's it's in the mafia they
have rules like they go you can't hit on
another guy's wife they didn't want him
selling drugs they you know and they
didn't want them gay and if they didn't
listen they killed them these were the
old times so is it homophobic to kill
someone because they're gay now I don't
disagree with the mafia rules but that's
how they do that's how they do you
don't kill someone because they're gay
okay so it is homophobic to kill someone
because they're gay no you don't kill
somebody right because you just keep
saying no say yes what do you mean is it
homophobic to kill someone because
they're gay yes yes that would be
homophobic okay I I just don't think
it's right to do it but I however that
you don't know what homophobic is yeah
I'm gay
it means you you mean basically
essentially that you hate gay people I
don't hate gay people right I don't hate
anybody I just want to go and have fun I
find it and fascinating that you don't
that you've never encountered the word
homophobia in your life in your 67 years
I just jumped 10 years Dan I just jumped
10 years old school
uh homophobia yeah
so that's why you kept saying Yeah when
I said uh old-school homophobia
yep who's putting no tomatoes up there
wait a minute I saw it what is This Love
This is Love I knew he had said it
before
he said it no shot yeah you found the
timestamp already yeah how did you do
that lovey I you Jimmy
that's when I did pretty good with the
chicks
that's when I go we're back to that okay
let's move on move on if you feel
someone's gay you don't need to point it
out correct although James is gay
I agree
okay
I concur I concur but it's not a matter
of agreeing it's he is gay yeah yeah
[Laughter]
say your medical opinion in your in your
professional opinion yeah is he gay
absolutely
indisputably all right tone it don't
push don't push tone it down tone it
down Zach
um we love we love we love our lgbtq uh
uh audience they're the greatest
um
that's the deal so when was this picture
with James Charles taken that was a
video they did in 2020 oh that's what
they did they collabed very recently
they collabed two months ago and two
months ago multiple times there was uh
YouTube videos there was tick tocks yeah
dude that's then then she really got a
she's got to stop what the that's
crazy I have a whole thing with James
Charles people let him are just letting
them off you like him he's a predator
right no he's disgusting he's bad news
yeah that's what my people just let him
off the hook more and more people are
just hanging out with James Charles like
it's all good like she's getting Roman
Polanski making room in Polanski look
normal
well
that was pretty bad what he did back
then that was really bad what he did
even now is he alive
or did he yeah he's like he's in did he
have sex with like a 12 year old or
something yeah
then he run away to Europe he's in he's
in France right yeah France and then
they gave him an award what'd they give
him an award for he got like best
director and everyone was like give him
a standing oh for like go it was called
a Ghost Rider writer or something you
know what's funny nobody even remembers
that they gave him they had to give
him that's that's just a child r word
yeah
12 year old
mm-hmm
so in a in an entertainment industry
where they always go how did this happen
how do we not see this happen
shut up pigs
freaks
Jojo
I'm not calling you a pig or a freak but
I am saying this is how this stuff
happens James Charles Don't Call Him a
fat pig I didn't I didn't
I just want to make that clear
um also Adam points out something
interesting here another Mac
McIntyre moment
JoJo being in the gc's group chats
alongside Pauline is the cherry on top
this is the JoJo siwa update the group
photo someone told me to change the pick
I don't know the context but that proves
that she was in the group chat and she
changed the group photo
um
how many group chats did this girl run
geez she had like unbelievable kids yeah
shots man
pretty much the career shop like will
she go to jail or anything bad happened
or no I doubt it just kind of the career
goes south James Charles should go to
prison in my opinion but yeah what
happens to somebody like him nothing
well the victims have to press charges
and I don't know if they I don't know if
there's an investigation or what I mean
this stuff takes time yeah I don't know
so when did JoJo collab with Shane
because that's also interesting three
months ago no way man so she's like
collected the Justice League of YouTube
predators
everybody
she's like um Samuel Jackson's character
how he brings them all together that's
her yeah
I see her car
why are you doing this uh
he didn't even put you on the main
Channel girl you got that Shane 2
treatment
no respect even who who's that Shane
he's another guy that like got canceled
in a
I won't say similar to Colleen but
this was for doing blackface and for
saying really inappropriate was she a
single things to uh kids one of them
kids right yeah it was about Willow
Smith yeah and then he also just like he
would say weird she's just absolutely
up nasties
not good stuff
he also got brutally canceled I would
say YouTube finds some beautiful people
my comedy started to look more normal
after dealing with these people yeah
that's weird to say it but well some of
the stuff you were just saying would
probably get other people canceled I'll
just be honest
or even you in the future
even me you think this no no Jimmy
oh when you make it big you're laying
the seeds right now my friend keep the
lookout for it JoJo the cat the the uh
the lemon drop and all that kind of
stuff I would stay away from it okay
yeah
because they're not candy
it almost like demeans them yeah if I
was like hey look at the luck over here
look at the water the Vodka what's
lalatka lot block is human yeah
get a load of this
it's lockers it's a lot to cover
whatever it is that's what you are
what if I'm just a few fashioned chicken
noodle soup hey look at the foreskin
over here yeah look at the foreskin on
this piece of chicken huh Jesus Christ
yeah
we have like this is this many people
over there oh damn
Shane is such a weird dude man
where's this guy she loves him
yeah I mean uh yeah he's been on the
show a long time ago okay before all the
all the crazy he was like the creator of
the moment for a long time he was really
pushing mad views yeah it was like the
first big comeback wasn't it like when
he started doing the documentaries
because before that he was kind of not
as popping for come back in the sense
that he wasn't popular and became
popular yeah I mean he was popular for a
while then yeah I mean he was getting
like a million per video honestly is he
flat now this guy pretty flat
uh he's still pretty Pop I mean this got
a million views three months ago but
he's a lot less popular than he was he's
not Jimmy Lee popping he's not 40 40 000
a day Pop I mean so even Selena Gomez is
barely that yeah
she's a big deal she has lupus by the
way Selena Gomez yeah geez how old is
she she's a kid
um I don't know 31.
30. oh she's 31. wow but that's it
that's the show um what else do we have
in the title uh the milk boys but we
didn't get to it we'll just have to talk
about on Friday there's still very
there's like no follow-up information on
it yet anyways
um so maybe we'll know more by Fred so
then the title becomes JoJo Seawall
defense Colleen Ballinger and Jimmy Lee
uh cancels himself with searing
homophobia
but we could put Jimmy Lee in the title
I don't know featuring Jimmy Lee
featuring Jimmy Lee Coho featuring Dr
James weiner
maybe that's confusing I don't know
maybe just uh thank you guys for the uh
cake just say you're welcome
congratulations I love you guys yeah
congrats on a million hard fight Brazil
we're coming back next year you earned
the hell out of those Millions well
we're coming back to Brazil next year
nice yep you're gonna brush up on that
and he's coming with me you're gonna
brush up on your language to go there
actually English people Spanish people
there believe it or not you speak
Spanish no there's a lot of people there
England that speak English so right but
normally they speak
two languages what is the other language
English and Spanish I see that you know
a lot about Brazil I was there a whole
month yeah yeah of course what a nice
day
good people real good people well they
have to be I mean there it's just a
phenomenon over there Jimmy Lee in
Brazil huge big huge come to Brazil they
said and Jimmy said I will
yep come to Brazil well it's been a just
a fantastic oh swoop has a tweet what
did swoop say
hit me with that swoop tweet I sent it
oh you did swoop hey Mayweather swoop
there it is oh it's finally happening
thank you mm-hmm he's interviewing
Colleen's um ex-husband who's got one
this is gonna be nothing my name is
Joshua David Evans I'm 39. Joshua we
have a lot to talk about obviously there
are allegations that have been levied
against you and we're going to get into
those but we have also alleged that you
are a victim as well there it is there
it is my team take very seriously so I
went from the boyfriend to the fiance
that to the husband to now I started to
feel almost like a character like I was
replaceable she loved the attention well
that proved to be true the status but do
I think she truly loves her fans I never
really felt like she did I think she
just loved what it gave her she's having
a few people over to the house and I was
like who they said Eric and when I walk
through those doors
reeked of alcohol in cigarettes we saw
this no yeah we did I just sent it and I
said tomorrow
oh this isn't this is she just reposted
it yeah she announced that it's coming
tomorrow did she put so much work in
this I know tomorrow I'm not doing
anything she said this interview is
shocking and no topic was off limits
let's go right now I did
let's you gonna watch this this
looks interesting is she interviewing
the husband's ex-husband she cheated on
him with a guy she was doing a show with
so the question to you guys because this
is all new for me I'm an older guy who's
the bad egg here is it Colleen it's a
husband correct well so here's it both
so her husband was getting a lot
of heat and they're dealing with her
ex-husband and there's been some
Revelations that has suggested that he
might just be a victim of hers another
victim and there's this girl an
interviewer the one with the blue hair
that's a swoop she's much more than an
interviewer yeah what is she she's just
she's the moment
she's the girl okay he is whoop
all right guys I really do have to go
thank you Jimmy it's been a pleasure I'm
Gonna Get You On That Highway podcast
before
it's beautiful
and everybody uh there's a Jimmy band
Meetup at Craig's Jimmy Lee fan meet up
at Craig's right now tonight tonight oh
my God we will not be there oh can I can
I say one more thing are we off no you
can say one more thing we have a live
shoot guys for comedy TV on Saturday
September 16th and our most famous stop
will be at Pink's Hot Dogs at two
o'clock and we invite all the H3 fans in
the Jersey Outlaw fans down there this
Saturday two o'clock at pinks don't miss
it fantastic thank you very much Jimmy
thank you Jimmy it's been a pleasure
it's been a joy a million wow wow
are you going to take that hairline to
Craig's are you going to wash it off
Craig's because Zach said if I take this
hairline he's coming down with me oh
okay yep there it is Zach will not be
there for them yeah he's not coming all
right guys thanks everyone for watching
uh I hope that you are able to glean
some enjoyment out of this uh it's off
the rails delivered on on the promise
promise of the plot
thank you guys we'll be I guess tomorrow
we're back leftovers is back okay yes
and uh that's tomorrow at 10 A.M we
bring truth to the people yo Jimmy
he he gave me a number he said have him
call his guy to schedule
I got the number
all right everybody
hold on
hold on Dan this is big this is big fomo
Happening Here
yeah let me give it to you don't read it
obviously
Jimmy's running so this is his um
publicist or Booker or something
why didn't you just do this after we go
up there well this is a big moment Dan
this is big fomo here I'll send it to
Zach and Zach will send it to you the
moment is just you texting a phone
number to Jimmy so just don't say it out
loud obviously no no let me say it or
the name
mics are going out
[Music]
all right
thank you